Starte.
Klappt es diesmal wirklich jetzt?
Ja, ich hoffe doch, wenn jetzt nichts weiter durcheinander kommt.
Spontane zum allerersten Mal heute. Starten wir die Hoffname.
Backstage ist beendet, jetzt treten wir in die volle Verantwortung für diesen Podcast.
Warte mal, ich hätte die erste Seite schon weggelegt vom Skript.
Genau, wir machen ja alles ganz spontan.
Jetzt müssen wir verantwortlich sein.
Also unter 140 Zeichen fand ich dich besser. Ja, hallo, hier ist der Mobile-Macs-Podcast Nr. 11 mit dem husenden Dennis und den 300 Followern. Oder hast du schon 300, Dennis?
Ja, 290, 395.
290 Follower auf Twitter. Dennis entdeckt neue Kommunikationsformen und auch Max.
Wer ignoriert sie eigentlich?
Dennis entdeckt Twitter.
287.
287. Jetzt hat er so viele Follower, jetzt muss er überlegen, was er sagen soll. Aber wir haben das eben schon durchdiskutiert.
Ich bin da noch nicht so ganz im Klaren, ich glaube, ich werde noch eine Weile lauschen. Aber ich glaube, man muss erstmal so ein paar personal friends da rein und sonst ist da irgendwie... Also die Follower, ich kenne die alle noch nicht.
Na du musst denen followen. Wer dir followt, kann dir vollkommen egal sein.
Ich muss jetzt auch erstmal Leute followen. Ich dachte, ich fange erst mal mit Leuten an, die ich kenne.
Achso, das hast du noch nicht getan?
Doch, euch beiden.
Du bist ein bisschen mager.
Das sage ich ja.
Nicht, dass ich sagen würde, es ist so uninteressant, dass wir wurschen.
Dann reicht es eigentlich auch.
Nö, du kannst ja unsere Follower durchklicken und dann kommst du auf interessante Ideen. Dann werden dir sicherlich eine Menge Leute sehr bekannt.
So werde ich es machen.
So sieht es aus.
Ich bin ja noch ein bisschen skeptisch, aber ich bin ja eh so ein neuer Schnickschnack.
Genau, du bist neu.
Ein bisschen langsamer.
Max, du lernst auch gerade was Neues kennen, nämlich? Du hast noch nie IRC gemacht. Das willst du mir jetzt nicht sagen.
Doch, irgendwann schon mal natürlich. Klar, immer so im Notfall. Aber ich fand es immer eher unangenehm.
Du hast ja gesagt, du programmierst Cocoa, kommen wir ja später noch zu, blablabla. Aber da gibt es zum Beispiel den iPhone-Channel, den Mac-Dev-Channel für Mac-Developer, dann gibt es den iPhone-Dev-Channel. Und da kann man einfach so laufen lassen den ganzen Tag. Und wenn du mal eine Frage hast, fragst du rein. Wenn du Glück hast, ist ein Profi da und der kann dir richtig schick antworten. Und manchmal ist auch einer, der weniger Ahnung hat als du, dann kannst du schick antworten.
Cool, das ist wie bei Twitter.
Ich kann sagen, ich bin gerade... Es ist schon ein interessanter Punkt. Wenn man wirklich IRC und Twitter vergleicht, und ich finde, der Vergleich muss auch mal gemacht werden. Nicht, dass er nicht schon mal irgendwo gemacht worden wäre.
Nicht, dass er nicht schon mal in dieser Sendung gemacht wurde.
In diesem Fall passt das auf jeden Fall ganz gut. Weil Twitter ist ja mit der Art und Weise, wie es benutzt wird, ich will jetzt mal nicht sagen, so wie es gebaut wurde ursprünglich, weil ich glaube, die hatten ganz andere Sachen im Sinn und deswegen bauen sie ja auch alles neu. Aber es ist ja an sich ein Chat. Und das Coole an dem Chat ist, dass du eben anderen Leuten folgst und damit so ein inklusives System hast. Während du jetzt im IRC musst du sozusagen erstmal bei Default dir alles anhören, also mitlesen, oder musst du natürlich nicht, aber du kriegst alles vor die Nase geworfen von den Leuten, die in dem Kanal sind, worauf du ja keinen Einfluss hast und kommst jetzt jemand in den Kanal, der dich nervt, dann nervt er dich halt mit, ne?
Und dann sagen die Leute, ja liest die Fak oder du bist im falschen Channel oder oder oder, so ne Sachen halt.
Genau. Und man kann nicht so schön feintunen, wie viel man so wirklich konsumieren will. Auf der anderen Seite, was du mit Twitter einfach nicht machen kannst, ist wirklich eine interaktive Diskussion führen, die jetzt über zwei oder drei Tweets hinausgeht. Also dieses, ich hab ne Frage und dann krieg ich da Response zu und auf die ein oder andere geh ich auch mal ein. Das funktioniert schon ganz gut, aber allein schon weil Twitter auch wirklich kein sinnvolles Redmodell hat, weißt du halt irgendwann gar nicht mehr, worauf die Leute antworten. Also du schreibst drei Sachen, dann kriegst du ne Antwort auf das zweite oder erste, was du geschrieben hast, dann kriegst du selber nicht mehr den Bezug dazu.
Mach ich auch meistens per Direktnachricht oder sowas dann.
Genau, das heißt da weicht man wieder aus und dann sieht man ja auch schon, dass das Kommunikationsmodell nicht mehr taugt. Bei IRC ist es halt anders. Im IRC wird halt einfach geredet und zwar eher so wie auf einer Party geredet wird. Alle schwatzen irgendwie aufeinander ein und es hängt immer so ein bisschen davon ab, worum es geht und wie viele Leute da sind, wie die gerade drauf sind, wie da die Dynamik ist. Aber gerade jetzt bei so einer Live-Radio-Sendung ist es halt cool, weil auf der einen Seite unterhält man sich halt über das, was die gerade irgendwie herausgefunden haben. Erwähnt es irgendein Thema, dann wird da drüber geredet. Also wirklich um das, worum es auch gerade in der Sendung geht. Und dann ab und zu gleitet es natürlich da auch immer so ein bisschen in das übliche Hallo und Tschüss und so ab. Aber IRC ist super und da wir ja Mobile Macs sind, sollten wir vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen erwähnen, wie man in IRC auf Mac gut benutzt. Und ich bin recht glücklich geworden mit Colloquy, was halt eigentlich so der...
Ich bisher auch.
Der Client ist, der total Mac-like ist, der wirklich sehr schön integriert ist.
Aber er zickt manchmal rum. Der macht den Channel auf und dann kommt aber... Du kannst was schreiben, aber es kommt nicht im Fenster und du siehst auch nichts. Wenn du den Channel dann wieder zumachst und nochmal neu rein aktivierst, dann geht's. Also es ist schon seit ein, zwei Jahren der Fehler und die meinten auch schon mal, sie hätten da was gefixt, aber irgendwie klappt es nicht. Ich hab das manchmal.
Es ist halt ein Open Source Projekt und im Prinzip gibt es eine bestimmte Nähe auch zwischen den Jungs, die an Colloquy arbeiten und an Ardium.
Es steht da oben drüber, Twitter stimmt.
Hört ihr mir überhaupt zu?
So ein bisschen.
Ja, lass euch nicht abdenken. Ich versuche euch gerade etwas zu erklären. Gerade dir, Max, wie auch immer. Was ich gut finde an Colloquy ist grundsätzlich die Konfigurierbarkeit. Die ist nämlich relativ straightforward. Ich könnte mir das eine oder andere wünschen, aber man kommt sehr schnell zum Ziel. Jeder Chat wird mit einer kleinen Sprechblase angezeigt. Klappst du auf, hast du gleich die User. Doppelklickst du in User, kannst du direkt anschalten. Vieles funktioniert, wie man sich das denkt. Was ich besonders cool finde, ist, dass wenn man jetzt direkt angesprochen wird, also mit deinem Login-Name, Doppelpunkt, dann kannst du erstmal flexibel konfigurieren, wie du davon in Kenntnis gesetzt wirst. Aber wenn du mal rechts, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ihr schon angesprochen worden seid, aber jedes Mal, wenn man angesprochen wird und das scrollt jetzt raus aus dem Bildschirm, macht er so einen kleinen Strich in den Scrollbar, wo das stattgefunden hat. So dass auch, wenn man so einen Chat mal ein paar Stunden nicht verfolgt hat, und das ist ja auch so eine typische IRC, dass man da so rumeiligt. Danke XJS fürs Anschauen. Siehst du halt sofort, da könnte was gewesen sein, was mich jetzt konkret betrifft, kannst du da relativ schnell hinscrollen, weil es ja direkt im Scrollbar und dann eben tun, was auch immer du für angemessen hältst. Also Colloquy ist auf jeden Fall erste Wahl, finde ich. Es gibt so, ja, ich hab auch das eine oder andere mal ausprobiert, X-Chat und noch diverse andere. Aber ich bin jetzt schon so lange bei Colloquy hängen geblieben, dass ich jetzt auch gar nichts anderes wirklich empfehlen kann. Also, man könnte natürlich jetzt irgendwelche Listen runterbeten, aber das bringt uns jetzt nicht wirklich weiter. Was ist denn noch schön? Man kann, ja genau, was mir auch sehr gut gefallen hat, was auch so ein Grund war, warum ich relativ schnell da hängen geblieben bin, er hat ein schönes Log-File, also ein XML-Log-File, gerade wenn man so Sendungs-Chats später noch archivieren will. Ja, ist Uhrzeit mit drin und kannst es aber auch wirklich gleich ordentlich bearbeiten. Du musst jetzt nicht erstmal mit Text-Parsing anfangen, sondern kannst es halt einfach in so einen XSLT-Skript reinschmeißen, was ja mein Sport XSLT. Da bin ich irgendwie sehr glücklich mit.
Du bist glücklich mit XSLT?
Ja, ich bin.
Du bist der erste, den ich kenne.
Was? Ich kenne auch ein paar. Das ist so ein Geheimtipp. Da kommt nicht jeder mit klar. XSLT ist super. Wollen wir über XSLT reden?
Nicht heute.
Wieso?
Weil ich hier so eine lustige Themenliste vorbereitet habe.
Wir müssen ja davon nicht abweichen. Ich könnte zumindest mal sagen, was XSLT ist, weil sich die meisten Leute jetzt schon...
Heißt das nicht mittlerweile noch XSL sogar?
Also Kurzeinführung XSLT, ich mach's ganz kurz. XML kennt jeder, ist so die universelle Datendarstellungssprache, die uns sozusagen jetzt aus dem ganzen HTML-Erbe rausgefallen ist.
Was auf dem Apple ja unter Punkt P-List ähnlich...
Überall benutzt wird, was alle Betriebssysteme heute benutzen, was im Internet einfach überall ist. Eigentlich sollte jede Webseite heutzutage in XML sein. Ist sie nicht, aber schön wär's. Aber überall, wo es wichtig ist, dass Dinge maschinenlesbar sind, sind sie halt in XML, in der Regel. Und da nun XML zwar offiziell human-readable ist, aber wenn's aufs Detail kommt, nicht wirklich für Humans gemacht ist, sondern doch eigentlich eher die Betonung darauf liegt, dass es maschinenlesbar ist, also von Programmen leicht konsumiert werden kann, ist es natürlich auch schick, wenn man Tools hat, mit denen man so ein XML-Konvolut und wenn's nur so ein IRC-Logfile ist, gut bearbeiten kann. Natürlich gibt's zahlreiche XML-Bibliotheken für alle möglichen Programmiersprachen, die im Idealfall dann auch noch halbwegs standardisiert sind. Also dass du sozusagen dieselbe Art und Weise hast, mit so einem XML-API zu arbeiten, egal welche Programmiersprache du benutzt, da gibt's halt so DOM und so ne Sachen. Das ist aber meistens auch sehr awkward und viele Leute benutzen was anderes. Und dann gibt's auch richtig noch als Teil der XML-Welt vom W3C spezifiziert das gesamte XSL-Framework. Und XSL besteht einerseits aus der Transformationssprache XSLT. Das ist eine Sprache, die du selber in XML schreibst. Also du benutzt XML-Syntax, um dein Programm zu schreiben. Und XSLT macht es dir halt sehr leicht, einen Baum, nichts anderes ist ja ein XML-File, also einen Datenbaum, in einen anderen Datenbaum zu überführen. Du kannst also sehr leicht diesen Baum, der in XML beschrieben wird, traversieren und transformieren. Das heißt, du kannst schnell mal aus dem einen was anderes machen.
Dann kommt da wieder XML raus oder nur Text zum Beispiel?
Da kommt dann auch wieder XML raus. Du kannst auch Text ausgeben.
Ich glaube, kein bleibiges Format.
Das Coole ist, ich könnte zum Beispiel jetzt so ein Log-File in eine Webseite, ist eine Sache von ein paar Minuten, dann bin ich fertig. Und vor allem, wenn es einmal läuft, weiß ich, dass es einfach läuft. Das ist dann wirklich auch super Rock-Solid. Und das läuft halt auch mit jedem XSLT-Transformer.
Also was ich an XSLT immer so ein bisschen furchtbar fand, ist dann, dass natürlich das XSLT ja auch selber wiederum in XML ist.
Ja, das ist gut. Du kannst auch deine XSLT-Programme mit XSLT-Parsen erzeugen.
Weil so eine IFSANELS-Schleife oder Schleifen generell, die sehen doch in XSLT dann gerne mal.
IFSANELS-Schleife, das ist ja genauso wie COSMA.
Ach, sie hat aufs Schleife gesagt und ist mir sogar aufgefallen.
Jetzt sagst du es selber.
Und jetzt sage ich es selber.
Jetzt kommt das haarige an XSLT. Also sowas wie, also ein IF gibt es noch. Schleifen gibt es so ja im Prinzip auch. Aber Variablen gibt es keine.
Und also ich fand ja da immer, ich hab mich irgendwann mal ein bisschen damit auseinandergesetzt und hab mich sehr geärgert, weil mein Gedanke war, ach, Menschenskinder hätte da nicht einfach irgendeine Sprache nehmen können, deren paar Tools reinflanschen und das dann nicht probieren, irgendeine Programmiersprache euch in XML auszudenken, weil das ist irgendwie...
Es geht ganz bewusst darum, etwas zu haben, was eben in XML ist, damit es auch in der XML-Welt sowas gibt. Programmiersprachen gibt es genug, wenn du was suchst, was irgendwie schön und einfach zu bedienen ist. Nimm Ruby, nimm Pearl, nimm was auch immer.
Ja, wenn man was kompliziertes, schwer zu bedienen, das nimm.
Coco, NSXMA, das ist ganz toll.
Ja, aber XSLT ist einfach super cool, ist extrem gut parallelisierbar, ist seiteneffektfrei und ist im Prinzip auch eine funktionale Sprache. Es ist jetzt alles viel Voodoo, das muss man nicht verstehen. Tatsache ist, XSLT eignet sich für manche Sachen so hervorragend, dass man da nichts anderes nehmen will. Für andere Sachen eignet es sich allerdings überhaupt nicht, wo man es eben beiseite lassen sollte. Also du schreibst damit nicht das, was du mit Ruby oder mit Perl schreibst. Aber du schreibst damit Sachen, die du eben ungern in diesen anderen Sprachen schreiben würdest, sodass man eher dazu übergeht, diese kleinen Transformationen in XSLT zu formulieren und dann mit einer anderen Sprache in so ein System reinzuziehen.
Vielleicht guck ich es mir nochmal an. Aber diese ganzen X-Pass-Sachen und sowas, die finde ich alle ganz schick. So als Abfrage und sowas.
Gibt es auch oKoKoR.
Das gehört aber dazu, darauf passen.
Ja, klar, ich weiß. Aber in anderen Sprachen, die einzusetzen, finde ich dann spannender als direkt in XSLT. Also damit bin ich wirklich nie so richtig warm geworden.
Aber du bist jetzt warm geworden mit oKoKoR.
Ich bin so ein bisschen warm geworden, doch ziemlich sogar. Ich hab angefangen, ich hab gedacht, es muss mal wieder was Neues her. Alle um mich rum programmieren für ihr iPhone. Nur ich immer noch nicht. Also hab ich mir das berühmte grüne Buch gekauft. Dritte Auflage ist Grün. Und wie heißt das? Ich weiß natürlich den Namen.
Aaron Hillegas heißt der Typ.
Genau. Und das Buch heißt... Soweit bin ich noch nicht.
Du machst Coco Touch, richtig?
Nee, ich mach beides. Es gibt aus unerfindlichen Gründen noch keine Bücher zum Thema Coco Touch.
Na, wegen des NDAs.
Jaja, eben. Also wegen des NDAs gibt's noch keine Bücher zum Thema Coco Touch.
Also angeblich hat die Erika Zardun in ihr Buch fertig und sie wartet nur noch auf das Lyft und NDA, weil es liegen 10.000 Vorbestellungen vor. Erika Zardun ist so ein...
Das ist die Hacke, also die Vorzeige-Hackerin von dieser unafraschal Apple Weblog, die auch am tuaf.com...
Die macht ziemlich viel auf jeden Fall.
Die macht ziemlich viel und die schreibt auch gerne mal Artikel für Tuaf darüber, hat offensichtlich auch... Hat damals so die ganze... Als es noch keine offizielle API gab, für jede neue Firmware-Version rauskam, als allererstes Mal die ganze Dokumentation gemacht und so was. Also die steckt da tief drin. Also sie war dann immer mal, jedes Mal, wenn eine neue Firmware von Apple rauskam und die halbwegs gehackt war, weil der erstmal für drei Tage abgetaucht und hat das Ding durchdokumentiert, die ganzen, was da so alles gibt. Die ist richtig tief drin und die hat wohl 12.000 Vorbestellungen für ihr Buch und kann das nicht ausliefern wegen...
Das NDAs. Das sogenannten fucking NDAs.
Das fucking NDAs.
Wo es immer noch nicht so sehr viel mehr Klarheit gibt, warum es dieses NDA gibt.
Ich hab eine Theorie gelesen bei...
Ich auch.
Ars Technica. Na sag mal. Patentschutz. Und zwar, dass es wohl so sei, dass man darf, um es patentieren zu können, darf es noch nicht öffentlich sein. Und man muss sozusagen, man darf die Information nur geschützt rausgeben. Und solange ein NDA drauf ist, egal wie löchrig der ist, gilt das Patent ab. Alles klar, können wir nichts dafür, wenn da irgendjemand quatscht. Und dass erst vielleicht die Patente durch sein müssen, oder eingereicht sein müssen.
Ich hab das auch gelesen, aber mal ehrlich, Patent auf einen API?
Das andere, was es noch gibt, ist, dass da halt eventuell ein lizenzierter Code von Third Party drin ist. Und die haben halt nicht die Lizenz für eine freie Doku.
Third Party?
Wobei, was soll das Third Party sein?
Was soll das sein? Das ist dasselbe OS, das auf jedem Mac läuft.
Ja, die irgendwelche Zusatzzeugs, ich weiß nicht, was die da noch mit dran haben. Das Location Zeug ist neu. Aber denke ich eigentlich auch nicht.
Ich glaube das nicht.
Das mit dem Patenten haut auch nicht so ganz hin, oder?
Ich habe wirklich keine gute Theorie. Ich wäre allerdings nicht überrascht, wenn wir sehen, dass es ein 2.1 gibt. Ein 2.1 Release, was ja auch schon irgendwie ein bisschen zirkuliert. Und dass mit diesem 2.1 nochmal irgendwelche signifikanten Änderungen kommen und dass sie sagen, ok, erst ab jetzt ist das eigentlich das 2.0, was wir immer haben wollten. Und auch erst jetzt wollen wir Bücher sozusagen darüber haben, weil die 2.0 musste halt raus mit dem neuen Telefon und überhaupt, und wir mussten schnell sein und wegen Android und überhaupt, und wir hatten Stress und überhaupt.
Könnte sein.
Aber auch das ist echt nur ins dunkle Orakel. Ich habe da mittlerweile gar keine wirkliche gute Erklärung.
Also beim 2.1 ist ja zur Zeit die Beta 4 aktuell und es ist so, dass dieser Push-Notification-ARP wieder entfernt worden ist.
Habe ich auch gelesen.
Das ist, das finde ich.
Heißt aber nicht, dass es nicht in der nächsten Beta schon wieder reinkommt.
Das könnte sein, aber ich finde es eigentlich gut, weil dieses Push-Notification ist so ein bisschen...
Haben wir schon mal ein bisschen in die Nase gerümpft, oder?
Was ist das ein bisschen?
Naja, jeder Service müsste sich erst dem Apple-System sozusagen anpassen. Du kannst nicht einfach mal so deinen eigenen Offline, wie sagt man, Background-Programme laufen lassen, die mit deinem Server quatschen. Das muss alles über Apple gehen und das kriegst du halt mit fremder Software nicht hin. Na wenn ich jetzt ein Aim-Client schreibe, von so einer Art Adium, nee quatsch, Adium ja doch, sowas wie Adium, und ich will zu so einem Java-Server connecten im Background, dann geht das nicht, weil ich muss das ja über einen Apple-Server machen. Wenn ich die andere Seite aber nicht beeinflussen kann, das Backend, wie soll ich das dann tun? Das geht nicht.
Wieso kannst du die andere Seite nicht beeinflussen?
Weil du einen kleinen schreibst.
Weil ich den kleinen schreibe und nicht den server dazuschreiben. Genau, das ist das Problem. Kannst du nicht bei allen Sachen machen.
Aber ich meine, das ist doch... Ich finde den Notification API eine ganz grandiose Sache.
Die ist eigentlich erst mal ganz cool, hat aber halt diesen Nachteil.
Aber erst mal nur grundsätzlich, dass sowas geben soll. Ob wir dann das immer noch toll finden, das ist eine ganz andere Frage.
Ich finde die Idee super. Also eine Verbindung offen haben, die nicht so ressourcenverschwendend ist, die halbwegs ressourcenschonend ist und sich darum das Betriebssystem kümmern lassen und Apple darum kümmern lassen, finde ich eine ziemlich großartige Idee. Und so einen Server, da braucht man ja auch nicht viel Server aufzusetzen, der muss ja nichts Großartiges machen, der muss ja nur eine Notification raussenden. Wie viele davon nutzen gleichzeitig irgendeinen Dienst?
Sie denken ja, dass mehr als ein Dienst pro Telefon läuft, weil wenn es nur ein Dienst wäre, bräuchte ich ja nicht Push-Notifications. Sie haben ja Angst, dass das Telefon leer saugt. Und sie wollen ja deswegen viele solche Connections über diesen Service bündeln.
Aber wenn du ein Programm schreibst, und nehmen wir mal an, du schreibst ein Programm, mit dem zum Beispiel dein Mac dir Bescheid sagt, zu Hause, wenn du eine Mail hast. Dann brauchst du dafür zum Beispiel schon mal gar nichts. Dann muss dein Mac dir das zu Hause Bescheid sagen.
Ich muss aber den Server auf meinem Mac schreiben, der sich mit dem Apple-Push-Notifications-Server verbindet.
Das ist doch kein Service, das ist wahrscheinlich ein stinknormaler HTTP-Request, soweit ich weiß.
Was es auch immer ist, es ist spezifisch nur für das iPhone.
Ja, natürlich ist es spezifisch.
Das heißt, du musst immer beide enden, irgendwie im Griff haben.
Wenn man den Server nicht im Griff hat, weil ich zu einem Service connecten will... Wenn man das Feature nutzen will, muss man speziell dafür die Serverseite anpassen. Klar, wenn man einen beliebigen Dienst macht, wenn man Facebook ist und man findet das geil, und man weiß, wieso Millionen Leute wollen das iPhone benutzen, dann bauen die das halt ein und es super ist. Und ich denke, so sieht Apple das auch. Das ist einfach ein Dienst, ein Angebot für alle, die alles unter Kontrolle haben. Was Dennis jetzt meinte ist, wenn man aber jetzt Software schreiben will für einen Dienst, wo man nur die Hälfte, nämlich den Client, im Griff hat, aber eben nicht den Server, weil man an den nicht ran kann, wie zum Beispiel ein Jobber-Client, dann geht das halt nicht. Sonst musst du halt dafür sorgen, dass in dem Jobber-Server, den du benutzt, dieses Feature-Einzug hält, und das wird halt so schnell nicht stattfinden.
Oder du baust dir irgendwo, setzt dir irgendwo einen kleinen Server hin, der dann eben sich um den Zwischenschritt kümmert.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Wieso? Natürlich.
Na, ich bin mit meinem Jobber-Server verbunden. Das ist irgendwie SSL, da sind Zertifikate, da kannst du nicht einfach mal eben irgendwas dazwischenkriegen.
Ich kann doch eine iPhone-Applikation schreiben, die sich nicht direkt mit dem Jobber-Server verbindet, sondern die sich mit meinem Jobber verbindet, und der verbindet sich dann dafür mit dem Jobber-Server.
Ja, aber das ist doch super unsicher.
Und ganz schön aufwendig.
Und super aufwendig. Na ja, aber dann hast du eine riesen Bug-Quelle, eine riesen Security-Problematik aufgemacht, um ein Problem zu lösen, was irgendwie... Aber klar, man kann jetzt immer so... Welche Alternative dazu? Die Alternative ist, diesen Dienst nicht zu verwenden und keine Lösung dafür zu haben.
Doch, der Dienst an sich ist cool. Sie sollten ihn halt nur nicht zwingend machen für Background-Applications.
Du meinst, man sollte auch Background-Applications erlauben? Na ja, ich kann schon Ihren Ansatz verstehen, dass Sie das erstmal nicht machen. Weil Sie sich einfach nichts aufladen wollen, was Sie dann später nicht mehr abwerfen können. Wie auch irgendwelche bösen Programme. Noch nicht haben wir noch drüber gerätselt. Jetzt hat Steve Jobs ja tatsächlich zugegeben, dass Sie einen Mechanismus haben, mit dem Sie Programme wieder vom iPhone schmeißen können.
Ist es denn diese Url, die da gefunden wurde?
Nein, es ist wahrscheinlich nicht diese Parallelocation-Geschichte, das ist nur, um jemand von dieser Navigation abzubringen. Aber Steve Jobs wurde dazu befragt, aufgrund dieses Gerüchtes nehme ich mal an, und er meinte, ja, wir können das tun. Wie hat er jetzt nicht gesagt? Ich vermute mal, dass es eine Blacklist ist.
Aber er meinte auch, Sie wären blöde, wenn Sie es nicht einbauen würden, und Sie hoffen, dass Sie es nie benutzen müssen.
Genau. Ich würde das auch fast unterstreichen, dass Sie da schön blöde wären, wenn Sie sich nicht die Möglichkeit geben, weil Sie können es auch immer noch nicht benutzen. Es werden natürlich gleich wieder viele ankommen und sagen, wie kann man so ein Telefon kaufen? Aber das sind eigentlich die Leute, die es eh nicht kaufen würden.
Also es gibt in den BossPress, in der neuen Version, gibt es eine Einstellung.
Das ist das Extra-Tool fürs iPhone.
Wer ein jailbreakt iPhone hat, kann mit der neuesten Version von BossPress, das hat eine Option, mit der das gekillt wird.
Stimmt, da kann man den Kill-Switch killen.
Den Kill-Switch killen sozusagen.
Und wieder einschalten, auch wenn man möchte.
Na bitte, dann ist doch alles super.
Na ja, es gibt nur für Leute mit jailbreak.
Achso, na ist doch auch super.
Ich glaube, das werde ich nutzen, weil ich möchte nicht das... Warum, also ich meine, warum...
Aber dein Telefon ist doch gejailbreakt. Das heißt, wenn die dir ein Programm unter dem Arsch weglöschen, was du aber weiterhin haben möchtest, dann kannst du es dir auch immer wieder drauf machen. Die Leute mit dem Jailbreak haben ja eigentlich nicht das Problem, sind eher die Leute, die keinen Jailbreak haben und die können sie darum nicht abschalten.
Irgendwannes iPhone klingelt man.
Du hast ja auch immer noch keins. Kannst ja erzählen, wo du eins herkriegst.
Ja, ich kriege ein iPhone, wie es aussieht.
Twitter macht es möglich.
3G. Twitter macht es möglich. Ja, also ich meine, ich kann das erst bestätigen, wenn ich es wirklich auf den Tisch habe. Aber ich habe es zumindest schon mal bezahlt.
Geld klauen lassen. Twitter macht es möglich.
Ja, und zwar aus Italien, frisch auf den Tisch. Und ich hoffe, dass es mir dann Dienste leisten wird, die das Geld auch wert sind. Keine Frage. Also das Geld wird es nicht wert sein.
Da kommt nichts.
Das werden wir dann sehen. Aber ich bin recht zuversichtlich, dass ich in der nächsten Sendung auch mal meine persönliche Perspektive präsentieren kann und nicht immer nur aus dem Dunkeln reden muss. Das ist doch mal was, oder?
Da kommt mal eine Spezialsendung.
Dann hab ich ein 3G-iPhone und ihr nicht. Sehe ich das richtig?
Das siehst du dann richtig.
Ich bin zuversichtlich, dass Apple wirklich zu dem Moment, wo ich das Ding in Betrieb nehme, alle Probleme ausgebaut hat. Haben sie nicht gesagt, dass das letzte 202-Update-Bug-Fixes enthält?
Das haben sie bei 201 auch schon gesagt.
Na, zwei Bugs, die schon gefixt sind.
Du warst damals auch Pressesprecher auf der Titanic, oder?
Wir werden es sehen. Trotzdem, das 202-Update soll ja angeblich auch im Bereich 3G schon irgendwas getan haben.
Nee, alle sagen, da wird es wohl nichts tun.
Also Apple hat gesagt, dass es das tun würde. Telegram hat auch gesagt, dass es das tun würde. Einige Leute haben auch im Voodoo-Zauber gesehen.
Das muss ja nicht alle Probleme sein, die damit auftreten, aber vielleicht bestimmte.
Aber mal ehrlich, wie viele Telefone gibt es jetzt? 5 Millionen oder so? Irgendwer wird immer dabei sein, der sagt, ich habe jetzt schlechteren Empfang, weil er sich gerade wieder so rumgedreht hat.
Das ist einfach so.
Und gleichzeitig wird auch natürlich das Gegenstück im Paralleluniversum sagen, bei mir sind jetzt 2 Bars mehr als vorher. Wenn Apple will, dann habt ihr auch 3 Bars mehr als vorher und bei gleichen Empfang. Die können da drehen, machen, wie sie wollen.
Aber ich kenne niemanden, der ein iPhone 3G besitzt, der nicht über schlechten Empfang klagt. Es ist wirklich durch die Bank weg jeder.
Wie viele kennst du denn?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 Leute glaube ich.
6 von 6 Leuten sind der Meinung, dass der Empfang schlechter ist? Mit?
Dass es so nicht geht. Dass es mit GPRS besser, also mit dem alten iPhone besser war? Ja. Solche Sachen wie, wenn ich 3G abschalte, habe ich schnellere Verbindungen, weil dann kann ich wenigstens Edge nutzen, im Gegensatz zu 3G, was eh nicht funktioniert. Was ich selber gesehen habe, ist, es steht oben eine schöne 3G da. Und sobald man versucht, irgendeine Internetverbindung, irgendeine Seite über 3G tatsächlich aufzurufen, ist das weg. Also ich habe damit bisher wirklich sehr, sehr schlechte Sachen gesehen. Also es ist so weit, dass ich im Augenblick tatsächlich ein bisschen zögere, dass ich mir im Augenblick kein 3G-iPhone holen würde, sondern erst mal warte, bis die Probleme geklärt sind.
Ich bin auch sehr gespannt, insbesondere was so die Akkulaufzeit betrifft unter der Maßgabe, dass ich natürlich sowas wie GPS wahrscheinlich erst mal wie ein Blöder die ganze Zeit eingeschaltet lassen werde. Und ich sehe mich dann schon wieder so zurückfallen in die Zeiten vor ein paar Jahren, wo man dann wirklich sein Telefon einmal am Tag aufladen musste. Aber da habe ich auch gelebt. Und jetzt habe ich halt mehr. Ich meine, jetzt habe ich ja auch einen ganzen Computer da drin. Ich bin positiv.
Nein, positiv ist es auf jeden Fall. Ich habe jetzt mein iPhone schön dadurch drehen das jetzt gerade leer, weil Twitter bietet ja keine SMS mehr seit neuestem. Also dass man keine SMS mehr bekommt, wenn man die direkt Nachricht kriegt oder sowas.
Twitter? Ach nee, echt? Ist Ihnen das jetzt zu teuer geworden?
Das ist Ihnen zu teuer geworden. Haben gesagt, das war ein sehr schönes Posting beim Twitter-Blog. Wir haben eine gute und eine schlechte Nachricht. Zuerst die schlechte. Blablabla, es wird abgeschaltet. Wir können uns das nicht leisten. Das ist alles viel zu teuer. Kostet so und so 4.000 Dollar pro User. Und ja, die gute. Wir überlegen, eine Lösung zu finden, wie wir es möglicherweise irgendwann doch mal wieder hinkriegen.
Toll.
Also es gab keine gute Nachricht, mit anderen Worten?
Sie lassen sich von der Telekom kaufen.
Okay, kennt ihr alle Identica schon?
Ich hab schon einen Account da.
Bei Identica bin ich Max.
Aber Identica wird allerdings auch nicht uns SMS kostenlos bringen.
Das wirst du erst mal sehen, was das ist, sonst wissen die Leute wieder.
Na klar, also Identica ist ein Groupen-Source-Klon von Twitter. Also so im Kern gleiche Funktionalität.
Da müssen wir jetzt kurz mal noch zuspulen. Twitter ist im Gegensatz zu Java, was ja verteilt ist, eher so singlesourcedtwitter.com. Das ist halt ein Laden und die machen das.
Und eine MySQL-Datenbank.
Und eine MySQL-Datenbank auf einem Rechner mit einer Steckdose. Mit einer Putzfrau. Jedenfalls ist es ein Laden und wenn die sagen, wir schalten das Ding jetzt ab, ist es auch weg. Und jetzt kommt das Identica.
Genau. Identica, wenn die es abschalten, ist es auch weg.
Aber wenn Twitter abschaltet, gehen alle zu Identica rüber. Also es gibt jedenfalls jetzt einen Ersatz.
Und wenn Identica abschaltet, gehen alle zu Twitter rüber?
Ja, also tatsächlich würde Twitter jetzt einfach abgeschaltet werden. Würden sie wahrscheinlich alle zu Identica gehen. Weil das ist so das, was das einzige, was so halbwegs etabliert ist und natürlich nahezu, zumindest eine vergleichbare Funktionalität aufweist. Ich hab mir das jetzt im Einzelnen noch nicht angeschaut, aber direkt Nachrichten zum Beispiel gehen noch nicht und so.
Es geht vieles nicht.
Es gehen keine Familien und so. Es würde dann wahrscheinlich auch sehr schnell das alles kriegen. Aber weder ist davon auszugehen, dass Twitter morgen abgeschaltet wird, wenn es sich nicht selbst abschaltet.
Das machen die immer alleine, genau.
Noch glaube ich, dass es von heute auf morgen gehen würde, weil die Twitter-User haben sich ja als extrem belastbar gezeigt. Also egal, wie viel Outage da war, man bleibt einfach da.
Also ich weiß nicht, Abtime von...
Einen halben Tag oder so.
Also knapp über 50% oder...
Das halten alle aus, weil einfach das Microblogging rockt. Und alle wollen da sein. Also extrem viele Leute finden diesen Dienst toll. Und ich zähle mich dazu. Und vor allem denke ich...
Das ist aber so ein bisschen Push-EM, oder?
Na ja, also so pushy ist es ja nun nicht, weil du musst ja mit deinem Kleinen schon auch explizit pullen. Ist schon pullig. Also einen Push-Service da noch mit einzubauen. Interessanter Punkt, ja. Also ich hab da mal drüber nachgedacht. Erstmal, die eigentliche Funktionalität nennt man Microblogging. Und ich find's eigentlich ganz okay, das von der Stelle aufzurollen. Dass man das System mehr so wie so ein Mini-Blogging-System begreift. Dass man das, was man schreibt, ist wie in einem Blog was schreiben. Weil es ist persistent, es hat eine URL, man kann drauf linken, lalala. Und es ist weniger so dieser eigentliche Chat-Diskurs, nur so wie Twitter benutzt wird von den Leuten. Ist es halt schon so, so, so Microblogging, dass es eben ans Chatten ranstößt. Es ist nicht da, wo IRC ist, weil IRC ist viel zu viel und viel zu schnell und viel zu wenig persistent. Aber es füllt halt genau diese Lücke aus zwischen den relativ schwerfälligen, langsam atmenden Blogs und eben diesem super hektischen Koksachat-IRC. Und dazwischen hast du irgendwie Twitter. Und die Zeiträume, die dort sozusagen erreicht werden, wo man das selber immer wieder so nutzt, also die Frequenz, die Nutzungsfrequenz, ist sehr interessant für Arbeitsgruppen. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass dieses La Conica, also diese Open-Source-Variante, gute Chancen hat, in Projekte einzuziehen. Stimm mal vor, wir hätten, na, das ist jetzt ein schwieriges Beispiel, aber angenommen, du hast jetzt ein Projekt mit 10, 20 Leuten, Firma. Du bist eine Firma. Da gibt es immer wieder dieses Problem, mit keiner weiß so richtig, was der andere tut. Jetzt sind ja viele schon dazu übergegangen, Instant-Messaging zu benutzen. Jabber, auch MSN, auch andere Sachen.
Aber keine Persistenz.
Die aber sehr genau, die erstmal keine Persistenz bieten. Und zweitens auch mehr so eine One-on-one-Diskussion ist. Das heißt, es reden immer nur zwei miteinander und damit kriegen die anderen auch nicht mit, was eigentlich gemacht wird. Incoming Microblogging. Wenn du jetzt quasi nicht chattest, sondern mehr so eine Art, und auch nicht IRC benutzt, weil auch IRC ist viel zu viel Aufmerksamkeit und ist eben auch nicht persistent genug. Wenn du also jetzt Microblogging benutzt, um die Kommunikation in deiner Firma zu machen und jeder sagt so was wie, keine Ahnung, was soll die Firma jetzt tun? Erfinden wir mal irgendwas. Messebau. So, ja, man arbeitet an so einem Projekt und man muss für eine Firma irgendwie so einen Stand aufbauen und jeder, der eine macht das Design, der andere macht die Logistik. So, der Logistiker sagt irgendwie, ja, ich hab jetzt mal die LKWs bestellt. Und ich hab irgendwie die Maße von der Messefirma bekommen. Und der Gestalter sagt, ich hab das und das gemacht. Also alle plappern sozusagen ein bisschen über ihren Progress.
Und jeder kann halt auch noch nachschauen.
Und du kannst halt auch immer mit Ad-Hm-Hm-Hm-Hm explizit Leute ansprechen und sagen, hier guck mal, das ist etwas, was dich jetzt auch interessieren sollte. Dann ist es halt so ein inklusiver Dienst. Du sagst halt, hier guck mal, jetzt schreib ich mal was Allgemeines, aber das sollte dich betreffen, bis hin zu einem Hin und Her auch. Bloß alle haben halt die Möglichkeit, das zu sehen. Und in so einer kleinen Arbeitsgruppe dokumentiert sich dann sozusagen der Workflow auch automatisch. Dass du nachschlagen kannst, dass du explizit auf bestimmte Sachen linken kannst. Das weiß ich, irgendjemand kriegt halt eine wichtige... Die Telefonnummern von diesem Messestand, die twittert da, in Anführungsstrichen, dann, oder lakuniziert, sagt man.
Aber es geht ja nicht so richtig, wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie 300 Follower hab, kann ich ja auch nicht, irgendwelche Nummern kann ich ja gar nicht mehr reinschmeißen. Es gehen dann 300 Leute, richtig?
Potenziell ist das, dass das ganze Internet Google geht über jeden deiner Tweets. Also ich finde mittlerweile, wenn ich so Ego-Surfing mache, Tweets von mir.
Also ich kenne, Sascha Lowe ist sehr stolz drauf. Ich glaube, wenn man seinen Namen eingibt bei Google, ist sein Twitter-Account auf Platz 1 mittlerweile. Ich finde Twitter einfach nur so lustig, ohne jetzt eine tolle Theorie dazu zu haben. Was mir aufgefallen ist, also gerade die Downtimes, wo bei dem Thema waren wir ja, das so von wegen, das hat die ausgehalten. Ich hab manchmal das Gefühl, dass das die Verbundenheit zu Twitter eher noch schlimmer gemacht hat. Also mir ist nämlich aufgefallen, dass, ich hab irgendwann mal mit Rauchen aufgehört vor zwei Jahren. Und mit Rauchen aufhören war immer so dieses so, oh jetzt noch fünf Minuten keine rauchen und dann nachher als Belohnung darf ich eine rauchen. Ah! Und bei Twitter ist es durchaus ähnlich, weil wenn Twitter da, oh Twitter ist down, das muss ich, ah! Man kann es nicht twittern. Und das hat, ich glaube, das ist, Twitter-User sind sehr leidensfähig. Das sind jetzt ihr spät nachgekommenen, wie du jetzt zum Beispiel, die diese schlimmen Zeiten nicht mehr erlebt habt, die jetzt einfach den ganzen Tag vor sich hin twittern können, als ob nichts gewesen wäre. Das ist, du nutzt das ja gar nicht, Junge. Wir mussten damals noch warten, bis der Server umgeging.
Ich bin halt nicht so abhängig wie ihr, ihr seid halt so eine, so eine, ähm, abhängigen.
Wollen wir uns wieder über Macintoshes unterhalten?
Ich glaub auch. Ja, und ich lerne immer noch Coco. Waren wir nicht da? Waren wir nicht da? Waren wir stehen geblieben? Du hattest den Namen des Buches gesagt, zu halb?
Aaron Hillegas heißt der.
Der Typ, und das Buch heißt irgendwas mit Coco?
Der macht die Big Nerd Ranch, der macht in Amerika so Schulungen für Cocoa-Programmierung. Und da kann man sich halt, kostet halt ein bisschen was, aber er ist auch wirklich ein Profi, also der weiß, was er erzählt. Der kann ein Buch, der kann gut erklären. Ich hab die erste Ausgabe von 2000, keine Ahnung, zwei oder drei. Und der hat es halt wirklich drauf.
Das ist jetzt eine Buchempfehlung oder was?
Das ist definitiv eine Buchempfehlung. Das brauchen wir gar nicht empfehlen. Das ist einfach jeder, der nachguckt und guckt, was er sich für ein Cocoa-Buch kaufen soll, wird am Ende bei diesem Buch landen.
Das ist das Standardwerk. Also ich hab ein paar Leute gefragt und jeder sofort. Aaron Hillegas, dieses Cocoa-Learning Cocoa, das ist relativ offensichtlich. Das ist auch gut erklärt. Das geht auch auf viele Details ein. Also es ist ja, gerade wenn man am Anfang irgendwas lernt und Xcode ist erstmal relativ umständlich, das zu lernen. Und den Interface-Bilder, das ist ja nicht nur einfach Code abtippen, sondern da muss man von da nach da mit der Maus rüberziehen und so was. Das sind wirklich auch die ganzen kleinen Zwischenschritte gut erklärt.
Das ist das Schwerste am ganzen Object-FC programmieren, das Xcode bedienen, wie das halt so geht erstmal. Also wenn man was ein bisschen mehr machen will als die Standard-Examples da. Und dann halt den Interface-Bilder, wie man seine Connections zwischen seinen Objekten macht. Wenn man das aber erstmal drauf hat, dann ist das eigentlich alles ganz easy.
Das finde ich aber relativ grandios. Also es ist, man schreibt relativ wenig Code, ist mir aufgefallen. Also ich muss dazu erzählen, das letzte Mal, dass ich nativ auf einer Plattform geschrieben habe, das war zu Windows NT-Zeiten. Also ich hab früher auf Mac programmiert und dazu System 7-Zeiten und ein bisschen noch zu System 8-Zeiten. Und dann jahrelang so relativ gar nichts gemacht. Und dann Web-Programmierung und dann mal zwischendurch ein bisschen NT. Und das war immer eigentlich alles ganz furchtbar. Und man musste ewig viel schreiben, bevor man zum Ziel kam. Und hier Coco ist wirklich, also so ein Programm zu schreiben und ein Web-View aufzumachen, wo man eine Webseite reinlädt. Das sind zwei Zeilen. Das sind exakt zwei Zeilen, die ich gebraucht habe.
Der Rekord ist Null Zeilen.
Wie cacke man die URL rein in Null Zeilen?
Du kannst doch so einen Input-Request da machen, den einfach connecten und dann kommt der und dann kannst du da dein Zeug eintippen. Und das connectest du einfach zum Input.
Ach, das kann man auch direkt verbinden. Den Teil hatte ich noch nicht. Aber es geht sogar mit Null Zeilen, dann Webbrowser zu schreiben.
Das gibt es auch von einem Apple-Programmierer, der vor ein paar Jahren einen Text-Editor hat, auch ohne Code, sondern nur mit Interface-Bilder zusammengeklickt. Ich weiß nicht, ob der auch speichern konnte, aber man konnte alles benutzen, machen, tun, underline und so. Aber die Apple-Examples sind schon ein bisschen fies, weil du kommst mit denen auch nicht wirklich weiter, weil ein bisschen Code muss man am Ende ja doch. Also man kann nicht alles mit einem Interface-Bilder zusammenklicken.
Ja, und auch gerade so dieses, das finde ich gerade zumindest am Anfang immer ein bisschen umständlich auf, zumindest wenn man es lernt, man weiß halt nicht, also wenn man Code sieht, dann sieht man Code. Dann kann man sich den angucken und dann hat man alles gesehen im Wesentlichen.
Aber man sieht die Connections nicht richtig.
Aber man sieht diese Connections nur relativ schwer. Bis man da erstmal drauf gekommen ist, dafür braucht man schon Literatur und sowas. Aber darüber hinaus macht es wirklich Spaß, das zu entwickeln. Man kommt mit relativ wenig Code relativ weit. Gerade so diese Verbindung zwischen GUI und eigenen Code habe ich noch nie so elegant verbunden gesehen. Also ich weiß jetzt, warum alle so von diesen Bindings schwärmen.
Es ist alles total großartig. Da müssen die Leute immer nur sehen und dann sind sie gleich so, ui.
Ich fand es auch einfacher als gedacht. Ich hatte so relativ große Hemmungen. Ich habe gehört, dass man es ja, klar, die Sprache geht relativ flott, aber bis man so das...
Ein paar Tage hast du die grundsätzlichen Sachen drin.
Die Sprache des Objective-C, das geht wirklich ratzfatz. Wenn man C kann und wenn man ein bisschen objektorientierte Konzepte gehört hat, dann liest man sich das Kapitel durch, sagt ja, klingt logisch und schlägt nachher noch mal ein paar Mal nach. Und klar, diese ganzen Frameworks, da kommt noch mal eine Menge auf mich zu, nehme ich mal an.
Das ist die eigentliche Fleißarbeit.
Da gibt es ja die Doku für. Und Tab-Completion, Code-Completion und so, das hilft ja alles. Denn die Variablenamen oder Methodenamen sind alle elendlich lang. Und die haben mit so einem Konzept, also es ergibt sich alles von selbst. Ich muss auch immer wieder alles nachlesen. Selbst von NS-Dring kann ich mir nicht alles merken. Da gucke ich einfach nach, das ist schon irgendwie da.
Wenn man einmal so weit ist, hat man ja meistens auch schon ein gewisses Ziel vor Augen, was man erreichen will. Und dann kann man ja auch gezielt danach suchen. Wobei wenn man so komplett ins, einfach nur erstmal ein bisschen rumspielen will, dann kann es ja schon am Anfang relativ frustrierend sein, wenn man erstmal eine steile Lernkurve vor sich hat. Aber die ist wesentlich einfacher, als ich gedacht hätte.
Ihr seid ja auch so beide so by doing-Leute. Ich könnte immer gar nicht anders anfangen, als mir erstmal so die 1000 Seiten-Fiebel komplett von vorne bis hinten durchzuwesen, bevor ich mich überhaupt an die Tastatur traue.
Nee, ich bin so ein by doing-Leute.
Also bei XSLT habe ich das gemacht.
Das gesamte Buch gelesen? Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so ein Buch komplett durchgelesen.
Das dicke Fette, was da im Regal steht. Doch, irgendwo steht ganz fett XSLT.
Im Buch liegt noch eins rum.
Ja, da muss auch irgendwo ein XSLT-Buch sein, wenn es da gerade nicht ist. Aber es ist so dick wie das XML-Buch, also dick.
Ich habe es gesehen.
Ah, da oben, XSLT 2.0 Cert Edition, da oben. Ich sehe es. Das hast du komplett gelesen?
Ja.
Dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich die ersten 100.
Also ich habe die 1.0 Version gelesen. Die 2.0 ist jetzt nur das Update davon, aber es ist genauso dick.
Ich schnappe mir mal so ein Demoprogramm, lasse es laufen und verstehe erstmal gar nichts. Und dann fange ich langsam an, so dran rumzupropeln. So wie ich auch vor ein paar Jahren mal diesen BitTorrent-Client in Python bekommen habe. Martin hat ihn ja so benutzt. Und dann habe ich halt da drin rumgepropelt und gemacht und getan. Ich hatte keine Ahnung von Python, konnte aber schon Änderungen dran vornehmen und schon Bugfixes machen. Und bin so in den Credits gelandet.
Also das ist so ein, da mache ich so ein bisschen die Zwischenvariante mittlerweile. Also am Anfang habe ich das auch so dieses komplett ins kalte Wasser springen gerne gemacht. Da bin ich doch mittlerweile ein Freund von gut aufgearbeiteter, kostenpflichtiger Information, seien es Zeitschriften, seien es Bücher. Aber dann auch relativ schnell nach 30, 40 Seiten spätestens.
Irgendwann muss man ja doch Hand anlegen.
Also nicht nur die Beispiele abtippen, sondern es auch ein bisschen ausarbeiten.
Ja, also...
Gucken und lernen macht Spaß.
Genau, du kannst ja in den nächsten Wochen auch mal berichten, wie es so vorangekommen ist und was du sonst noch so für Pitfalls entdeckt hast, damit die Leute, die an Programmierung auch interessiert sind, da vielleicht auch sozusagen weiter motiviert werden zu Kunden. Weil ich glaube, man muss ja mal so ein bisschen geschubst werden. Man muss schon so dieses, was die anderen programmieren, auch alle, das kann gar nicht so schwierig sein. Es ist eigentlich nicht schwierig. Wenn man die Zeit hat und das Interesse, dann ist eigentlich schon alles getan.
Und dann ein cooler Tipp noch, der fällt mir an, ich glaube, ich hab den schon mal genannt, aber wenn wir gerade dabei sind, muss ich noch mal schnell abwerfen. Beim Interface-Bilder kann man ja mit Control-Click auf die Objekte klicken. Und man muss mal mit Shift-Control draufklicken. Das ist schick. Auf jeden Fall noch mal ein bisschen mehr Infos. Besonders wenn man vollgepackte Durchsage hat. Na, man kriegt so ein, was ist das? Ich hab keine Ahnung, so eine Art Menü. Es kommt einfach mitten an der Fläche, wo man klickt. Und da werden alle Objekte untereinander gezeigt, die sich dort an der Stelle befinden. Weil manchmal hat man ja einen Textview, einen Scrollview, einen Window, einen anderen Fenster, weißt du schon, so mehreren Ebenen und der zeigt die untereinander und dann kann man sich eins aussuchen. Das war vorher mal ein bisschen schwierig, das in der richtigen Tiefe zu erwischen.
Ja, ich bin ja hier zwischen der letzten und dieser Sendung mal angesprochen worden. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr von wem oder von wo eigentlich. Ich nehme meine Quellen gar nicht mehr wahr. Aber es gab eine Frage zu iTunes, und zwar zum Podcast Directory. Haben wir da schon mal drüber geredet? Ich glaube nicht, nicht so explizit.
iTunes und Podcast Directory?
Genau, es gibt auch in iTunes, also im iTunes Store, und damit sozusagen auch in deinem Programm iTunes, gibt es ja das Podcast Verzeichnis. So wie du nach Musik suchen kannst, und nach Fernsehsendungen und nach Filmen, kannst du auch nach Podcasts suchen. Und das Podcast Verzeichnis von iTunes ist eigentlich, naja, ich würde sagen, ist eigentlich die Referenz. Weil die anderen Podcast Verzeichnisse taugen alle nichts.
Also andere Programme als iTunes zum Verwalten von Podcasts meinst du?
Nicht zum Verwalten. Mir geht es jetzt erstmal nur um das Verzeichnis als solches. Also das Ranking und die Möglichkeit zu kommentieren, also dass der überhaupt gelistet wird, so wie unser da ja auch vertreten ist.
Wenn du im iTunes Store bist, also wenn du ein Podcast bist, was gibt es da so?
Das so verzeichnest, meinst du das, also nicht deine eigene, sondern das, was dir angeboten wird? Genau.
Das iTunes Podcast Directory. Also wenn du auf den Store gehst und dann suchst, dann findest du halt alles Mögliche, unter anderem halt auch das. Und es gibt auch ein Portal dafür, wo ja auch Podcasts gefeatured werden. Da gibt es ein Team für jedes Land. Gibt es da immer so ein, zwei Leute, die sich darum kümmern. Also ich hab mal gehört, dass es in Deutschland zwei Leute sein sollen, vielleicht noch mehr. Ich hab auch gehört, dass sie in Berlin sind, aber man weiß es ja nicht so ganz genau.
Die sind doch bestimmt in München.
Nee, ich glaub, die sind tatsächlich in Berlin. Aber vielleicht ist das auch eine alte Information.
Gibt es in Berlin ein Apple Office?
Ich glaub nicht, dass es ein Apple Office ist. Wie gesagt, das ist eine ungesicherte Information, aber ich hab die mal von einem Apple-Mitarbeiter gehört, von daher hat das eine gewisse Credibility. Aber ansonsten weiß ich jetzt nicht so richtig.
Ich glaub, da kann ich mal versuchen, ein wenig mehr Informationen zu dem Thema aufzutragen.
Das ist ja nun auch nicht so wichtig, wo die sitzen. Also, die Frage, die aufkam, war, weil es gibt ja hier, wenn man auf das Podcast-Portal im iTunes-Store geht, gibt es rechts diesen Sidebar, wo drin steht, was steht da? Top Podcasts, glaube ich. Das heißt, es gibt da ein Ranking.
Da, wo Oliver Kalkohofe oder wie heißt der Typ da, irgendwie auf dem ersten ist gerade?
Genau. Top Podcast heißt es, und da ist jetzt Kalkohofe, Smart-Scheibe die Nummer eins. Dann kommt irgendwie Tagesschau in 100 Sekunden, oder was? Dann Galileo von ProSieben, dann Sendung mit der Maus, Sat.1, dann kommt Best of YouTube und so weiter und so weiter. Und die Frage war, wie kommt man denn da rein? Und wie kann es sein, dass ganz neue Podcasts teilweise von heute auf morgen auf Platz eins landen? Und ich glaube, die Frage war so ein bisschen mit so einem Unverständnis darüber, wie das eigentlich tatsächlich funktioniert.
Wie geht denn das bei MTV?
Das geht bei allen gleich. Der Punkt ist. Ja, das iPod Podcast verzeichnet im Prinzip nichts anderes als RSS-URLs. Also diese Podcast-URLs, da wo der RSS-Feed mit der Enclosure drin ist, das ist das einzige, was sie da eigentlich wirklich dauerhaft drin haben. Und alle Informationen, die sie dir anzeigen, wenn du da so rumsurfst, holen sie aus dem Feed. Das ist eine der tollsten Eigenschaften von dem iTunes Podcast Directory, dass sie sozusagen alles aus dem Feed holen. Das heißt, wenn irgendwas falsch ist, ich ändere es halt im Feed und es ist dann innerhalb eines Tages in der Regel in iTunes geändert. Während alle anderen hier, wie sie alle heißen, hat man damit gestartet, ich glaube, ich habe es schon wieder eingestellt, keine Ahnung, ist auch wirklich egal, weil es funktioniert einfach nicht. Dann gibt es noch so ein paar unabhängige Podstar und so. Die holen sich einmal den Feed, dann speichern sie die Hälfte irgendwie ab und wenn sich dann später was ändert, dann kriegen sie die Änderung nicht mit. Völlig beknackt. Während du bei iTunes über den Feed alles steuern kannst, du kannst zum Beispiel deinen eigenen Podcast auch wieder delisten. Du kannst da einfach ein Element in dein Feed reinbauen und sagen, blogg mich.
Und wo meldest du dich an?
Ich melde mich einmal, also ich muss mich hier einmal einloggen im Account und dann submite ich die URL von dem Podcast.
Deswegen haben sie so schnell die neuen schon drin, weil du meldest dich mit deinem neuen an. Die sehen, da ist ein neuer. Sie sehen, wie oft er runtergeladen wurde und...
Nein, nein, nein, das sehen sie nämlich alles gar nicht. Nein, also um den Mobile Macs Podcast da reinzukriegen, muss ich nichts anderes machen als auf Podcast submitten, irgendwie klicken. Podcast anmelden, was auch immer wie das heißt. Übersicht, ralala. Warte mal, ich bin hier auf dem falschen Portal gerade, oder? Nee, ich bin auf dem richtigen Portal. Ich erinnere immer an die Stelle, wo das irgendwie ist. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall kannst du halt eine URL eingeben und ich gebe auch nur die URL ein. Und dann sage ich zack und dann zeigen sie einem kurz die gepaarsten Metadaten, die da drin stehen, ob das irgendwie so okay ist, und dann sage ich okay. Und dann kriegst du irgendwie eine E-Mail, und zwar auch die E-Mail-Adresse. Die E-Mail-Adresse ist die E-Mail-Adresse in dem Feed, die von demjenigen, der zu kontaktieren ist, der zuständig ist mit diesem Podcast.
Damit man keine Sternen-Podcasts allowenzen kann.
Kannst du machen, aber trotzdem gibt es die ganze Kommunikation. Es hat nichts mit dem Account zu tun, den du da benutzt, um das zu submitten. Und ich weiß nicht, warum man sich einloggen muss, wahrscheinlich damit verhindern wollen, dass nicht am laufenden Meter irgendwas submitted wird. Tatsache ist, dass der Podcaster unter der E-Mail-Adresse die er in seinem Feed hat, dann eine Notification bekommt. Hier wurde irgendwie aufgerufen, wir gucken uns das mal an. Dann schaut da irgendjemand drauf. Wer, warum, wie und so weiter, keine Ahnung. Die schauen sich das halt irgendwie an. Und dann wird das nach einer Weile approved. Das dauert in der Regel selten länger als einen Tag. So, und dann wird der halt aufgeführt. Das ist durchsuchbar, kommentierbar und alles. Logo ist ja automatisch da, weil das steht alles im Feed. Und du kannst ihn dann halt auch mit Sternchen bewerten, als das übliche, so mit deinen Kommentaren. Du kannst halt sagen, hm. Und viele Leute glauben, dass das jetzt sozusagen für das Ranking in dieser Liste Top Podcasts zuständig ist. Ist es aber nicht. Sondern das, was dort gezählt wird, ist nichts anderes als die Anzahl von neuen Abonnierungen, die mit dem Programm iTunes durchgeführt worden sind. In einem Zeitfenster von, soweit ich weiß, 24 Stunden. Das heißt, sie zählen eigentlich nichts anderes, als wie häufig Leute gesagt haben, oh, diesen Podcast möchte ich abonnieren. Weil das ist die einzige Information, die sie eigentlich wirklich bekommen. Und was du eben meintest mit heruntergeladen, das sieht iTunes nicht.
Meinte ich ja mit abonnieren.
Naja, aber das ist ein Unterschied, weil viele Leute glauben nämlich tatsächlich, dass das irgendwas mit der Popularität des Podcasts zu tun hat. Was man so nicht sagen kann, weil die Leute könnten danach alle gleich wieder auf unsubscribe klicken. Und es hätte keinen Einfluss auf diese Statistik. Von daher ist die auch etwas zweifelhaft. Es ist in gewisser Hinsicht das einzige, was sie tun können.
Also hast du eigentlich gerade den Leuten verraten, wie sie ihre Podcasts pushen können?
Nee, du kannst sie dadurch gar nicht.
Doch, andauernd abonnieren, wieder abbestellen.
Achso, naja, keine Ahnung, ob sie da noch irgendwie mit dem Account und den IP-Adressen, das weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das wirklich so viel bringt. Man fühlt sich dann immer ganz toll, wenn man da irgendwie erwähnt ist und denkt so, ha ha, wo war?
Die bei der Nordscheibe müssten das so gemacht haben, oder ist das gut?
Naja, das ist halt einfach...
Ich hab mich jetzt sofort abonniert.
Ja, aber ich meine, du siehst halt jetzt natürlich hier bekannte Sachen, wir sind da natürlich...
Wir sind da auch, oder?
Naja, wir sind, ich weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt gerade in diesem Top-Podcast zu finden sind.
Ich war da auch mal, oder?
Aber wie gesagt, auch das sagt nichts darüber aus, wie viele Leute uns hören oder wie viele Leute uns abonniert haben. Es sagt nur was davon aus, wie viele Leute uns in den letzten 24 Stunden mit iTunes abonniert haben. Ich scroll mal durch hier, aber ich glaube, das ist ohne uns. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass wir da dabei sind. Scroll, Scroll, Scroll, schöne viele Icons.
So lange kann ich ja ein bisschen von Android erzählen.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Hab ich das jetzt ausreichend erklärt hier mit den Podcasts?
Ja, wir haben jetzt gelernt, wie das Ranking bei Podcasts gemacht wird und wie wir dafür sorgen können, dass unser Podcast ganz nach oben kommt. Jungs, ihr wisst jetzt, was ihr tun müsst.
Ich habe aber schon noch einen Nachtrag.
Du hast einen Nachtrag?
Ja, genau. Weil jetzt weiß ich nämlich auch wieder, worum die Diskussion ging. Es ging nämlich auch um Statistiken. Und ich wollte mal erklären, wie ich Statistiken mache.
Für Podcasts? Das hatte ich mal für eine spannende Frage, weil ich sitze nämlich vor dem Problem, euch zählen zu müssen auf unserem Server. Und wie zählt man jetzt vernünftig? Vielleicht ich erläutere einfach mal ein bisschen die Problematik, die ich so sehe. Oder?
Mauer!
Und zwar, ich probiere jetzt nachzuzählen, wie viele Leute hören uns hier eigentlich zu. Es muss eine ganze Menge sein, weil Dennis hat trotz drei, jetzt nicht nahe treten wollen, langweiligen Tweets, 300 Follower.
Das kann nur mit seiner außerordentlichen Popularität zusammengehen.
Das muss mit Dennis Popularität zusammenhängen. Wir haben hier 80 Zuhörer, ihr seid ziemlich viele, aber wir wissen natürlich nicht genau, wie viele, und das würden wir ganz gerne wissen. Und nun kann ich dazu die Lokfalls auswerten.
80 Zuhörer, du beziehst dich auf den Stream. Ich weiß nicht, haben wir das jetzt schon erwähnt, dass wir hier auch gerade wieder live streamen.
Ja, ich...
Ach so, Irk meinste...
Nein! Also Leute, die jetzt gerade eine Aufzeichnung hören, ein Podcast, wissen wir auch gar nicht, dass wir schon wieder streamen. Letztes Mal haben wir das doch so ein bisschen ad hoc gemacht, jetzt haben wir es angekündigt. Wir werden streamen.
Fast eine Stunde vorher.
Und du sagst, 80 Leute hören zu bei uns?
Ich weiß nicht, vorhin waren es 80. Ich hab jetzt die aktuellen Zahlen. Egal. Auf jeden Fall probiere ich rauszukriegen, wie viele Leute haben sich das denn überhaupt angehört. Dann ist natürlich zum einen mal das Problem, Downloads ist ja nicht gleich anhören, weil ich bin zum Beispiel ein Kandidat, der dazu merkt, sich sehr viele Podcasts runterzuladen, die ich dann aber nie höre. Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich auch so Fälle, wo zum Beispiel jemand dann über die Webseite hört, direkt auf den Play-Button unten bei Mobile Macs klickt. Da gibt es gar nicht so wahnsinnig wenige von. Und die klicken auf Play, die hören sich das dann vielleicht zur Hälfte an. Wie zählt man die? Erzählt man die zur Hälfte rein? Und ja, das ist tatsächlich eine ganz interessante Frage, wie du glaubst, dass man Podcasts zählt. Also ich bin jetzt etwas hergegangen, ich hab die Request genommen aus der Log-Datei, hab geguckt, wie viele Beit haben die jeweils geladen. Hab diese Zahlen aufsummiert und hab die Gesamtgröße des Podcasts geteilt. Und dann kommen wir so auf knapp 2500-2300 Downloads im Augenblick.
Echt, so viele Leute hören mich?
Nein, so viele Leute laden das runter.
Genau.
Ich will von jedem einen Dollar.
Dennis, so kommen wir hier nicht weiter.
Ein Dollar nur, Jungs. Die braucht keiner mehr.
Der Dollar hat keinen ordentlichen Kurs, Dennis.
So wird das nächste Mal.
Also, ähm, darf ich da mal was zu sagen?
Sag da mal was dazu.
Also, erstens, mir ist das mal auf... Also ich hab mit Chaos Radio Express am Anfang halt immer geguckt, so was geht denn eigentlich? Ich hatte eigentlich nur so die normalen Logfile-Auswertungen und die sind ja so ein bisschen für Systemadministratoren, aber nicht wirklich für Leute, die Content anbieten. Und das heißt, das Einzige, was erstmal da war, waren so ein Hits. Da hab ich mir gedacht, naja, wenn jetzt einer die Datei runterlädt, dann gibt's halt so ein Request, der wird dann da irgendwie gelockt, Datei wurde vollständig runtergeladen, graus alle Theorie. Weil viele Leute verwenden entweder ein iPhone, was auch beim Hören mehrere Zugriffe macht.
Und zwar alle paar Megabyte.
Genau, weil es halt in so Chunks lädt. Und eine ähnliche Geschichte hast du halt bei Speed Downloadern, den sogenannten, die vor allem unter Windows eingesetzt werden, die sozusagen da die Langsamkeit, ich weiß ja nicht warum das langsam ist, aber Tatsache ist, es gibt diese Programme, die auf der Datei aufgesetzt werden, die halt über mehrere Verbindungen parallel laden.
Das kommt von der Connection Shape, da darf eine Connection so und so schnell sein, also machen sie einfach acht Connections und dann sind sie halt...
Wer shape die Connection an der Stelle?
Na die Provider.
Ach die Provider? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
In Amerika ist das irgendwie häufig wohl.
Okay, ich hab das gestellt, dass es diese Tools gibt, die machen dann halt verschiedene...
Was?
Nicht durcheinander reden. Was hast du gesagt?
Mit diesen Speed Downloadern kann man einen Server schön in die Knie treiben, falls man das unbedingt vorhat, weil...
Viele Connections ist nicht gut.
Es gibt da Leute, die machen dann 300, 400 Verbindungen auf einmal auf und damit kann man schon die meisten Server relativ gut laden.
Genau, da hab ich nämlich mal nachgezählt. Diese Methode, das hatte ich dir ja gesagt, dass du das mal so machen sollst, im Lockfall steht ja, wie viel Bites runtergeladen wurden mit jedem Hit. Und wenn man das einfach mal addiert und teilt durch die Größe der geladenen Datei, also sortierst du das sozusagen nach URL. Genau. Und dann hab ich das halt mal gemacht und ich hatte ein Fehlverhältnis von Hits zu Downloads von bis zu 1 zu 400 oder so. Also ich hatte 400 mal so viele Hits, wie ich Downloads mir ausgerechnet habe. Diese Methode, also ich nenne das Complete Downloads, in Ermangelung eines anderen Begriffs. So ein Complete Download hat sich jetzt gezeigt, ich mach das jetzt ein Jahr lang bei Car's Radio Express, dass es eine relativ stabile Größe ist. Also ich hab nie wirkliche nennenswerte Ausrisse gesehen in dieser Zahl, die sich nicht irgendwie erklären ließen durch höhere Nachfrage wegen tolles Thema oder warum auch immer.
Dann warten wir auf unseren Videopodkasten, dem sich deines auszieht.
Naja, damit können wir es lesen. Trotzdem ist es nicht ausreichend, weil ein paar Sachen macht irgendwie das kleine Skript, was ich gerade benutze, nicht. Und wenn du jetzt fragst, wie kannst du das machen? Erstens, Complete Download ist ok. Zweitens, wir sollten Einfluss nehmen auf das Blog, dass eben die URL, über die im Web runtergeladen wird, anders ist, als die, die über den Podcast runtergeladen wird. Dann kann man die schon mal auseinanderhalten. Hauptsache, man hat eine Software, die das wieder zusammenbringt. Und natürlich sollte die Statistik jeden Download auch separat speichern mit Datum, sodass man eben später auch sehen kann, an welchem Tag ein Download stattgefunden hat. Dann kannst du halt die Quellen unterscheiden und so weiter. Das wär mal so ein Tool, was unbedingt sein muss. Dann haben viele Leute nach BitTorrent geschrien. Na ja, eigentlich kann man sehr viel besser mitzählen bei BitTorrent, wenn man selber einen Trecker betreibt. Und den müsste man eigentlich machen. Das ist so ein bisschen mein Traumsetup für einen Podcast-Server. Du betreibst deinen eigenen Trecker, du releasest deinen Podcast, machst eine Torrent-Datei draus und die verwendet halt deinen eigenen Trecker. Man schreibt ja in die Torrent-Datei selber rein, welcher Trecker verwendet werden soll. Das zeigt dann eben auf deinen Trecker. Der Trecker trägt auch nichts anderes als deine Dateien. Und Clients, die aus diesem Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerk, was über diesen Trecker vermittelt wird, einen vollständigen Download haben, die also alles geladen haben, melden sich an diesen Trecker und sagen, ich bin jetzt ein Seeder. Das heißt, der Trecker kann diese Information, wie häufig runtergeladen wird, im Prinzip problemlos generieren. Und wenn man dann eine zentrale Datenbank hat, wo sowohl das Tool, was die Weblog-Files auswertet, getrennt nach Quellen, wenn dann auch noch dieser BitTorrent-Trecker so modifiziert wird, dass man immer eine Datei runtergeladen wird, dass er das auch mitten in diese Datenbank reinschreibt mit Datum, dann hätte man eine hervorragende Basis, die mehrere Probleme löst. Erstens, man hätte eine wirklich akkurate Download-Statistik, also zumindest so akkurat, wie ich glaube, wie es geht, trotz BitTorrent. Und du kannst halt dann auch noch ein BitTorrent-Podcast-Feed rausgeben. Leider unterstützt iTunes das nicht. Aber Miro zum Beispiel unterstützt das.
Was ist Miro?
Miro ist so ein Open Source Podcast-Client, der an sich ganz toll wär, wenn das Directory dahinter nicht so bekloppt wär.
Das ist ein bisschen langsam und ein bisschen hässlich.
Ja und vor allem, sie lassen keine Audio-Podcasts zu, aus welchen Gründen noch immer.
Weil das ein Videoplayer ist, oder?
Nein! Du kannst problemlos in Miro auch Audio abonnieren und...
Mit Directory meinst du, dass wir das verzeichnen, was die so anbieten?
Genau, so wie das Podcast von iTunes, was ich gerade besprochen habe. Miro ist an sich ganz hübsch. Die Jungs sind auch irgendwie korrekt. Ich hab mit denen auf der Republika gesprochen. Das ist ja auch vorgesprochen. Und ich hab denen echt ins Hirn geredet. Hab denen gesagt, Leute, warum bitte? Ich meine, die machen da so einen dicken mit irgendwie Freedom. Das Ding hieß mal Democracy Player. Aber warum jetzt Democracy nur mit Video erreicht werden darf, mit Fernsehen, aber nicht mit Radio, das geht nicht rein in meine kleine Rübe. Die hätten es vollkommen in der Hand. Die könnten so einen Service zum Beispiel aufbauen. Und auch hier irgendjemand anders könnte das tun. Wäre ein super geiler Service für Podcaster. Übrigens. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Sowas müsste man machen. Und dann hätte man halbwegs akkurate Statistiken und man könnte bitteren verwenden, was natürlich auch eine super Methode ist, um Bandbreite zu sparen.
Aber man hätte zwar schöne Download-Zahlen, aber man hätte immer noch keine höheren Zahlen. Das ist nämlich, das ist mir so aufgefallen, das ist so diese Zahlenspielerei.
Ja, na ja, doch. Ich sag dir mal, warum ich der Meinung bin, dass Download-Zahlen höherer Zahlen sind. Ja. Wenn du in iTunes einen Podcast abonnierst und vorausgesetzt, du benutzt jetzt so The Apple Way, d.h. du hörst es dann auch in iTunes oder du hörst es mit einem iPod. iTunes schaut, ob du Sendungen regelmäßig verfolgst. Und wenn du einen Podcast keine Sendung mehr hörst, was ja so typisch ist, ich hab jetzt gerade keine Zeit mehr, das weiter zu verfolgen, dann stellt dir das Abonnement ein. iTunes hört auf, den Feed zu laden.
Aber guck mal, also was ich jetzt gerade hier habe z.B., wenn ich mir mal meine Podcasts direkt hier angucke, dann ist da das meiste, das ist da nicht gehört und ein ganz kleiner Bruchteil ist angehört.
Ja, aber irgendeiner wird dann auch aus-timen.
Ja, ja, die Timing hin und wieder mal auch. Und gerade hier z.B. bei HR2 der Tag, der heißt glaube ich schon gar nicht mehr so, das heißt jetzt HR2 Kultur oder irgendwie sowas. Da klicke ich dann immer wieder drauf und sage, ja lad den weiter runter, weil hin und wieder hole ich zwischendurch mal eine von den 10 Folgen, höre ich mir dann mal auf meinem iPhone an. Dann sind aber alle 10 Folgen runtergeladen worden, aber ich habe nur eine davon gehört. Ich glaube, so wirklich akkurat ist das.
Nein, ich sage nicht, dass es akkurat ist. Diese Download-Zahle sagt nicht aus, wie viele Leute deinen Podcast hören, aber sie geben dir eine gute Vorstellung davon, in welcher Größenordnung sich das bewegt. Und ich glaube, dass da nicht mehr als 10% Abweichung ist.
Das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz wissen wir, werden wir nie genau erfahren, wie viele Leute uns zuhören, außer live. Obwohl, auch wenn da zwei davon...
Auch so ein Livestream, die sitzen jetzt alle, bohren sich in der Nase und chatten miteinander. Glaubst du, heute ist wirklich einer zu?
Also jetzt gerade nicht mehr.
Wir müssen wieder zurück zum...
Wir haben jetzt sowieso noch eine halbe Stunde Aufmerksamkeit, weil wir uns... Dadurch, dass wir so spät angefangen haben, rollen wir jetzt hier direkt ins Chaos-Radio rein.
Wollte ich was über das Android erzählen?
Ja, wollte du.
Ich wollte was über das Android erzählen. Das ist ja das alternative Handybetriebssystem von Google.
Das zukünftige noch. Gibt's ja noch nichts.
Das gibt's noch nicht. Es soll jetzt im Oktober, glaube ich, von T-Mobile Amerika das erste Gerät rauskommen. Irgend ein HTC-Gerät vermutlich. Oder ziemlich sicher. Und jetzt hat's Google nach langen Hin und Her auch mal wieder geschafft, eine neue Version der Software, also des SDKs, rauszubringen, mit dem man entwickeln kann. Und siehe da, sie haben die Benutzeroberfläche komplett überarbeitet.
In der 09?
In der 09.
Da muss man dazusagen, dass es ja lange Zeit irgendwie sich die Developer beschwert haben, dass wohl Google das SDK nur an Spezialkundenfirmen oder irgendwie Entwickler rausgibt, aber wohl nicht an alle. Für den 09 gibt es jetzt wieder für alle.
Genau, das waren zum Beispiel die Entwickler, die damals, Google hat ja damals auch so einen 1.000.000 Dollar Preis ausgelobt, wer da in die engere Auswahl gekommen ist, für die beste Programmidee, die haben schon vorher Zugriff drauf gehabt, aber im Wesentlichen war das fast so, oder war eigentlich nicht großartig anders als bei Apple, so alles hinter verschlossenen Türen und bla, bla, bla und weiß ja toll was und niemand konnte was sehen. Und jetzt haben sie vorgestern glaube ich endlich mal wieder eine neue Version dieses SDKs rausgebracht.
Was ist da noch neu jetzt außer einem neuen User-Interface? Wie neu ist denn das User-Interface? Sieht es ein bisschen anders aus oder funktioniert irgendwas total radikal anders?
Es ist nicht so radikal anders vom Desktop, wie zum Beispiel das iPhone ist, aber es ist schon touchiger geworden. Man hat so einen Desktop, ähnlich wie beim iPhone auch, zum Beispiel dieses Springboard. Da kann man allerdings noch so kleine Widgets drauflegen, von denen es standardmäßig natürlich die obligatorische Uhr gibt. Und irgendein Google-Widget, das werden sicherlich relativ schnell mehr werden. Man kann sehr schön hin und her scrollen, das sieht auf den ersten Blick ziemlich aus wie beim iPhone, hat aber so ein hübsches Hintergrundbild drin, das ist echt ganz niedlich gemacht, dass da auch so ein leicht räumlicher Effekt auftritt. Und es ist so ein bisschen so, ja, da besteht die Hoffnung, dass da mal ein bisschen Konkurrenz zur Apple entsteht. Das ist alles nicht so schön wie beim iPhone gelöst, also gerade so die Menüführung und so, das ist leider...
Ist das nicht genau das, was die Leute am iPhone so begeistert, dass das mit dem User Interface einfach mal okay ist?
Ja, natürlich begeistert das.
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ein Telefon, über das man dann immer noch sagen muss, na ja, das User Interface ist nicht so gut, aber ansonsten ist es ein Konkurrent. Entweder man wird auf der Ebene des User Interfaces...
User verpasst nicht alles.
Nee, aber User Interface ist das Neue. Und das ist das, was die Leute jetzt neu entdecken, weil Features gab es schon vorher. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht genau...
Na ja, es ist auch noch die Frage, man hat eine Plattform, für die man relativ leicht entwickeln kann.
Das ist jetzt hier gerade ein Simulator, ja?
Ich schieb mal diesen Simulator ein bisschen hin.
Der läuft jetzt unter was?
Unter Java? Nee, das ist eine native Applikation, soweit ich weiß. Für Mac? Ja, für Mac, für Linux und für Windows gibt's das. Dann hat man hier unten so eine kleine Programmeübersicht, wo das alles drin ist. Da sind hier ein paar hübsche Alkons und sowas. Dann gibt's hier Google Maps natürlich, wie sich das so gehört. Wie man das so erwartet. Und das ist schon ganz schick. Und ich glaube, es ist insofern eine echte Konkurrenz fürs iPhone. Es kann vom User Interface ja nicht mithalten. Aber es ist schon offensichtlich, sie sind ein bisschen freundlicher zu ihren Entwicklern. Wieso ist denn eigentlich das Netz bei dir heute gerade so lahm? Das fährt mir schon die ganze Zeit über auf. Guck mal, was ich hier für schlechte Download-Raten habe.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Fortschritt, weil ja auch gestreamt werden muss. Fortschritt im Gegensatz zu irgendwelchen anderen komischen Folgepacken, Multimedia, Telefonen.
Es ist auf jeden Fall zu diesen ganzen Java-Handys natürlich ein gigantischer Fortschritt.
Wir hören noch mal ein bisschen mehr von dem User-Interface. Wir sitzen jetzt hier vor diesem Simulator.
Unser Liter kann aber nach wenigstens höher, wollte ich sagen, können natürlich jetzt nichts sehen.
Wir schauen jetzt mal ein bisschen und dann beschreiben wir das mal. Okay, da ist so ein riesiger Tab und dahinter verbindet sich im Prinzip genau das, was beim iPhone, sozusagen verstanden, nicht klar ist.
Du kannst hier was nehmen, du kannst zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt hier sagen würdest, ich möchte jetzt gerne den Alarm-Clock, also den Becker, den hätte ich gerne immer, dann nimmst du den und lässt ihn hier irgendwo reinfallen, dann liegt er da rum.
Also kann man wie auf dem Desktop seine Icons so platzieren, wo man möchte. Was man ja beim iPhone auch machen kann, mit länger festhalten.
Na ja, innerhalb des Grids kannst du es beliebig positionieren.
Man kann ja auch, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel mal, ups, falsche Taste, was ein bisschen doof ist, dass man natürlich an vielen Punkten doch wieder Tasten braucht. Zum Beispiel gibt es hier diesen Menu-Button und man neigt dann dazu, wenn irgendwas auf einem Display ist.
Also kannst du nicht auf diese Lasche da klicken, und dann geht die hoch.
Die haben so unterschiedliche Funktionen. Da ist eine Lasche und da drunter ist die Menu-Taste und die Menu-Taste hat nicht eine andere Funktion?
Nein.
Doch, doch.
Das ist doch alles wieder total kompliziert.
Dann kann man hier zum Beispiel noch ein anderes Widget. Was nehmen wir hier mal für ein Widget? Nehmen wir hier mal das Search-Widget. Schmeiß ich jetzt nochmal mit drauf. Dafür ist gerade nicht genügend Platz da. Also probier ich mal auf die Seite da nochmal eine Uhr abzulegen.
Wie viele unterschiedliche Menüformen haben die denn da eigentlich? Ich sehe jetzt hier schon drei oder vier auf einmal.
Was? Also eigentlich gibt's schon dieses...
Du hast diesen Screen, auf den wir jetzt gerade schauen, der sieht aus wie so ein MacOS Desktop.
Der sieht aus wie ein normaler Desktop.
Dann hast du diese Lasche, die da hochkommt, das sieht aus wie ein iPhone Desktop. Und dann hast du eben noch was hoch gemacht.
Na, das ist das ganz normale Menü. Das ist in jedem Programm.
Genau, dann hast du noch dieses Overlay-Menü, das sieht aus wie... Das sieht aus wie so eine gemauerte Wand. Und dann hast du eben noch ein anderes Menü gehabt, mit so Pfeilen.
Achso, ne, das ist, wenn ich hier auf Add klicke, dann geht einfach...
Dann hast du noch was an.
Nein, dann geht ein Dialog an.
Och, das ist doch furchtbar. Grauenhaft. Das ist doch die totale Hölle. Ich meine, du hast vier Sachen, die du hintereinander benutzt und alle sehen anders aus.
Und noch eine liegt über der anderen, dabei brauch ich jetzt den Rest da hinten gar nicht mehr. Also...
Ja, das ist so halbtransplant.
Aber ist egal, ich will gar nicht so viel...
Ich sag dir, die Jungs haben von User Interfaces einfach nicht genug Ahnung.
Soll ich dir auch sagen warum?
Und das Hauptproblem meiner Meinung nach ist einfach, es gibt keine Target-Plattform. Es gibt da einfach nicht das Gerät, von dem man mal weiß, wie groß der Bildschirm ist und wie viele Tasten es hat.
Und sie wollen wieder alle gleichzeitig glücklich machen und das geht einfach nicht.
Also ich würde mal sagen, dieses Telefon, ich wünsche ihm eine große Zukunft, weil es hat etwas, was das iPhone nicht hat. Und zwar eine wirklich halbwegs vernünftige offene Plattform. Und die vermisse ich ja noch beim iPhone. Wir haben gerade über dieses Notifikation...
Wir wollen aber jetzt nicht wieder über die offene Plattform streiten.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, aber ich meine...
Hatten wir schon mal.
Nee, hatten wir schon mal. Nee, aber ich meine im Sinne von...
Ist Android offen?
Android ist auf jeden Fall deutlich. Also zum Beispiel dieses... Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie offen es ist, weil ich hab noch nicht für entwickelt. Aber es gibt hier diese Widgets, die ich mir direkt auf den Desktop legen kann, ganz offensichtlich.
Aber bestimmen, wie die Apis aussehen, tut schon Google.
Bestimmen, wie die Apis aussehen, tut wahrscheinlich schon Google.
Google ist der Lead Developer. Und damit stehen die auch in der Pflicht, eigentlich das Design voranzutreiben. Aber wenn die es jetzt nicht machen, wer sollte es dann tun? Dann müsste sich irgendeine offene Gemeinde finden, die sich jetzt dessen annimmt.
Aber am Ende ist ja der Kunde, ist halt wie HTC, Firmen, die das Gerät rausbringen. Und die haben natürlich schon auch die Macht zu sagen, wir würden es gerne benutzen. Und Google braucht ja auch Benutzer von dem Betriebssystem. Sonst kommen sie ja nicht weit. Die sagen ja wiederum, wir brauchen folgende Features. Und dann muss Google ja nachreichen, oder? So ein bisschen Macht haben sie ja schon auch.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass das nicht so ohne Weiteres geht. Und das ist ja das große Problem gewesen von Nokia bisher mit den Providern. Dass die Providern so einen riesigen Druck ausgeübt haben. Und Google hat dasselbe Problem mit den Herstellern. Weil die ja alle auch gegenläufige Interessen haben.
Dieses Jahr wird da nicht wirklich was kommen, oder?
Es ist der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner über alle Hersteller. Und ich meine, hast du dir angeguckt, was HTC, also dieses Diamond des Windows, das ist furchtbar.
Ich hab's mir aber nicht genau angedrückt. Ich hoffe auf einen, ich hoffe... Das ist grauenhaft. Dieses Windows-Gerät noch nicht. Jetzt sind ja Videos aufgetaucht von dem Prototypen mit besagten Android drauf. Ich hoffe mal, dass das eine Plattform ist, auf der man vernünftig entwickeln kann, die ein bisschen offener ist als die von Apple und dass da mit Apple gezwungen wird, sich weiter zu öffnen.
Wir hoffen und wir glauben, aber wir wissen...
Konkurrenz belebt das.
Ja, aber wir schauen das auf jeden Fall an. Ich will jetzt ja auch nicht wieder den Fanboy miemeln. Ich bin nur wirklich sehr skeptisch, was die Konkurrenzfähigkeit anderer Plattformen angeht, weil ich halt einfach das...
Ja, aber bis zum Ende des Jahres haben wir dich so zum Cocoa-Programmierer gepusht.
Dann glaubst du auch wieder an den App.
Ja, aber gerade...
Dann mach dich so richtig zum Fanboy. Also noch viel besser, du machst dich selbst zum Fanboy.
Aber es ist...
Können wir Android abschließen?
Aber du hast noch den nächsten Daden nicht erreicht. Den Cocoa-Skyle-Daden.
Ich hab mir... Wie viele Apples hast du dir eigentlich schon getätowiert?
Übrigens, du hast gefragt im Twitter hab ich gesehen, was an meinem Bild nun so berühmt ist. Das Bild mit dem Stuhl in meinem Twitter-Account. Wo ich auf dem Stuhl sitze, der Hacker von der Seite. Und zwar, welcher Kongress war das?
21c3.
21c3, da wurde die Apple-Werbung so ein bisschen durch den Kakao gezogen, indem das einfach nachgemacht wurde. Und dann saß ich gerade im Club so auf dem Stuhl, wie das halt in dem Bild ist, und dann meinte Hucke, sagen wir mal hier die Namen genau, mit seiner tollen Kamera, alles klar, ich mach jetzt mal so ein Foto, und dann blende ich irgendwie hinten, dann machen wir schwarz und weiß, und dann siehst du halt auch genauso aus, das kann ja jeder, also was die können, und dann hat er dieses Foto gemacht, und das war auch gleich der Hit.
Denn es bezieht sich halt auf die erste Apple-Kampagne mit den Silhouetten, als sie noch richtig schwarz waren. In 21c3 gab es halt am Anfang zwei Mock-ups sozusagen davon. Einmal, das war auf Basis von Der Devil, der Film, der gerade rauskam, also so ein Muskel-bepackter Super-Hühne, so, im Schattenriss.
Sah auf jeden Fall nicht aus wie ein Nerd.
Genau, das war aber auch bewusst.
Das war für mich aber nicht wie ein Nerd.
Das war ja genau das Spiel, was wir da gemacht haben. Das ist so ein Super-Typ, ist auch Hacker. Und dann haben wir noch eine Variante mit einem Mädel. Und das war, da muss ich gleich mal drüber nachdenken, wer war denn das? Auch so ein Comic-Film-Ding, oder? Nee, das war Diana Rigg hier, das war Schirmschau und Melone, wer ist denn auch gleich? Die Schauspielerin, die Figur. Na, mein Gott.
Hier muss es einer sagen. Im Irr, los Jungs, ihr seid schneller.
Ja, wir haben Irr, wir haben Irr, wir sollten vielleicht hin und wieder mal sowas durchsagen.
Wikipedia lebt schon.
irc.freenode.net Seid mal kurz leise.
Emma Peel, wer war zuerst, der Chat oder ich? Echt, ihr wisst nicht wer.
Ich sag noch mal kurz den Chat durch, irc.freenode.net und da Mobile Macs ohne Bindestrich. Weil direkt in den Kommentaren.
Genau, sagt ihr das eigentlich was? freenode.net?
Äh, nicht so richtig.
Das ist so der IRC-Server, wo die ganzen Programmierer rumgammeln. Also alle nennenswerten Programmierer-Chats sind eigentlich auf Freenode, oder?
Weiß ich nicht. Also ich bin auf jeden Fall immer da und da ist halt MacDev, wie ich schon erwähnt hab.
Chaos Radio ist da auch. Aber wir sind vor allem irgendwie auf freenode.org. MAPL, und so weiter. Und dann haben wir halt Dennis die Leute gemacht und das gefiel natürlich allen sofort, weil das sah einfach mal so cool und nativ aus, und dann war das einfach mal so das Logo. Deswegen ist Dennis so berühmt. Dennis ist sozusagen unsere Ikone im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Es gibt immer noch ganz viele Leute, da gibt's ja auch so einen Button-Sticker von, so einen blauen, das war ja mit blauer Hintergrundfarbe und einem, also der Button jedenfalls. Und da gibt's immer noch ganze Menge, die das irgendwie an sich dran rumtragen oder an ihren Taschen oder wie auch immer.
Wenn du dich komplett schwarz anmachst, wirst du auf der Straße erkannt?
Das sind alles deine Follower jetzt?
Der Witz ist, dass ich manchmal im Club immer noch so da sitze und dann Leute kommen und sagen, ah, du bist es.
Echt?
Ja, wirklich, wirklich, wirklich. Und es gibt auch ganz viele Leute, die gleich das Bild gesehen haben und wussten, also so aus der Seabase oder so, damit wir nicht so viel zu tun haben, die gleich wussten, dass ich das bin. Und das hat mich schon so ein bisschen erstaunt. Also man kann mich wohl wiedererkennen, warum auch immer.
Es sieht aber auch nach einer gewissen ungesunden Körperhaltung aus.
Absolut, aber wer es kennt, erkennt es auch wieder.
Ich meine, andere Leute sitzen ganz anders auf dem Stuhl, als die an ihrem Rechner sitzen.
Nächste Gesprächsthemenkarte.
So, iPhone hatten wir jetzt schon ein bisschen. Die 202 ist halt rausgekommen, Bugfixes. Haben wir noch nicht, ist noch nicht gehackt.
Wir sind ja glücklich, dass wir überhaupt die 201 besitzen.
Kann man nicht viel zu sagen, ja.
Wir sollen ja nicht so viel über das iPhone reden. Ich glaube, wir haben schon genug iPhone gemacht heute.
Na, ich würde gerne mal irgendwie auch was zu Leopard 10.5 erzählen oder 10.6, aber da tut sich ja nicht viel. Es gibt Updates, gibt es neue Seats, aber an die kommen wir ja nicht ran, im Gegensatz zu früher.
Da gab es auch Fragen, glaube ich, im Blog.
Und zu Snow Leopard gibt es auch keine neue Beta, keine News, nichts durchgesickert, auch keine internen Seatings, gar nichts.
Das stimmt. Nichts.
Nichts, so richtig gar nichts.
So richtig überhaupt nichts.
Das ist aber eigentlich normal. Die bringen immer erst mal zur WWDC eins raus, dann gibt es eine ganze Weile nichts und dann gibt es in zwei Wochen Rhythmus los.
26 Kommentare auf unser Posting zu dieser Aufnahme. Meine Güte.
Hey, ich schalte hier mal der Reina frei.
Ja. Wollen wir gerade mal durch die Fragen durchgehen, damit wir das nicht am Ende machen? Dann können wir unsere Zähne... Unsere Meinung über Refurbished Macs von Apple. Keine Ahnung, ich hatte noch nie einen.
Ich auch nicht, die sind halt ein Stück billiger. Es sind welche, die wahrscheinlich mit den zwei Wochen Rückgaberecht über online kaufen, die zurückgeben.
Aber Apple schummelt auch ganz schön mit dem Preis erlassen. Neulich ist das mal bekannt geworden bei FHCKlog, dass sie sagen, hier iPod Refurbished ist so und so viel Prozent billiger. Bezieht sich aber nicht auf den aktuellen Preis des Geräts, sondern auf den, zu dem das Gerät irgendwann mal verkauft wurde. Obwohl es mittlerweile 40 Euro billiger ist. Das ist schon ein bisschen unfallig. Die schummeln halt auch. Dann ist die Frage, ob wir rechtzeitig fertig sind vor Krausradio? Keine Ahnung. Dann Abfresh. Benutzt ihr das? Schon mal gehört? Ich versuche immer mal wieder es zu benutzen und verzweifle jedes Mal daran.
So richtig toll ist es leider nicht, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Also es ist ein Programm, mit dem man, das dafür gedacht ist, um seine Programme auf dem aktuellen Stand zu halten.
Genau.
Indem es einfach nachguckt, welche Programme hat man.
Und sie geben sich auch wirklich viel Mühe. Aber sie haben es auch nicht so leicht.
Weil es gibt keinen einheitlichen Standard, wie die Leute ihre Programme anbieten. Und darum bietet, wie die zum Download angeboten werden. Und darum wird das eine so abgedatet, das andere so abgedatet. Und wäre es natürlich eigentlich ganz schick, wenn man da dieses Sparkle Toolkit nehmen könnte, was ja in vielen Programmen eingebaut ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob das sich da verabschieden kann.
Ja, aber Sparkle ist halt dafür gemacht, dass die Programme das selber verwenden. Und da, wo es einen Sparkle Feed gibt, benutzt Abfresh natürlich auch denselben Feed.
Okay, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Jaja, also das machen sie schon. Ansonsten haben sie halt irgendwelche andere Minze. Ich hab sie mir jetzt im Einzelnen hier angeschaut. Aber es gibt halt immer wieder Tools, die sie gar nicht installieren können, weil die halt mit einem komplexen Installer kommen. Dann schmeißt es dir das halt irgendwo hin. Das find ich so ein bisschen, hm. Manchmal machen sie, was ich ja ganz cool finde bei Abfresh, ist, dass sie wirklich so Web-Browser aufmachen und dann so, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo ich hinklicken muss, klick du mal. Klick mal so lange, bis die Datei sozusagen gefunden ist, die ich erwarte. Auch ganz cool.
Das ist schon alles, da sind schon viele gute Ideen drin. Für mich ist leider mal der Nachteil, dass im Endeffekt so dieses, was ja das Ziel ist, das Fernziel von so einem Programm, dass man einfach nur ein Programm startet, das vielleicht mal über Nacht laufen lässt, und man hat alle Programme auf dem aktuellen Stand, dass das leider einfach noch nicht erfüllt werden kann und auch noch lange weit davon entfernt ist.
Was mich am meisten aber erstört, ist, dass er häufig einfach meint, irgendetwas sei neuer. Also es gäbe für irgendetwas eine neue Version, wo es einfach mal nicht stimmt. Entweder vertut er sich mit irgendwie, 1.10 vs. 1.10. So was da, so die Geschichten. Das ist manchmal so ein bisschen fishy. Dann bietet er mir ja auch Updatesprünge an, die Geld kosten. Wo ich einfach nicht updaten will. Ich würde gerne so ein Level einstellen können, wo ich sage, nichts was kostet, nichts was irgendwie ein Major-Release überspringt.
Und manchmal kriegt er auch die Version einfach nicht richtig raus. Nämlich, dass er dann nur irgendwie die Major-Version anzeigt, aber unten die kleine Änderung gar nicht so richtig.
Genau, und dann werden Beta-Versionen angeboten. Was weiß ich hier, Audacity 1.3.3. Das sagt er mir 1.3.5.Pri ist available, aber ich will sowas gar nicht haben.
Ist aber auch alles nicht so leicht mit den Versionsnummern tracken.
Nein, nein, ist es nicht.
Da geht ja auch bei Subversion nicht. Die größte Revision ist auch immer die neueste Version.
Keine Frage. Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass das einfach ist. Ich sage nur, wenn man jetzt der Meinung ist, dass Upfresh diese Update-Pine vereinfacht. Ja, es gibt einem auf jeden Fall weitere Werkzeuge, um es einfacher zu machen. Manchmal stoße ich auch wirklich dadurch erst auf Updates, die ich sonst nicht so mitbekommen würde. Aber es ist nicht so jetzt total Rock-Solid. Also das sollte man im Hinterkopf behalten. Aber schön gemacht, schönes Projekt und ich finde sowas auch gut. Ja, dann, was haben wir hier noch? Da wird weiter diskutiert über... la la la... das mit dem Mac... mit dem Refurbished Macintosh. Da muss man da nicht drauf eingehen. Ist ja schön, wenn ihr euch das auch selber beantwortet hier. Kann man sich gegen Diebstahl versichern? Geht das? Wie macht ihr das? Gute Frage.
Ich glaube gegen Diebstahl versichert einen so ziemlich gar niemand. Doch. Ernsthaft?
Doch, doch. Ist das nicht bei dieser Gravisversicherung sogar mit dabei?
Oh Gott, da würde ich noch mal ganz genau ins Kleingedruckte gucken.
Genau, guckt mal ins Kleingedruckte. Ich hab immer sowas in Erinnerung, dass dem so ist. Und es gibt natürlich auch Versicherungen, die man für sowas abschließen kann.
Versicherungen gibt es doch für alles.
Das ist eine Frage, das Geld ist. Kensington-Schloss kann man das sichern? Ja, MacBook Air kann man auch mit dem Kensington-Schloss sichern. Oder? Nee, warte mal, jetzt weiß ich es gar nicht.
Hat das einen Kensington-Schloss?
Ich glaube ja. Nee, da liegt grad keins, das ist in dem An. Warte mal, ich glaube ja, da steht auch in Specs.
Das hätte doch alles für einen Apple-Kensington-Schloss, oder? Außer am iPhone.
Ähm, außer dem iPhone. Ja, wobei, bei Graves sind sie ja tatsächlich dazu übergegangen, jetzt ihre Klauerei über USB zu machen. Du darfst das MacBook Air nicht in die Hand nehmen, weil da so ein rotes USB-Kabel drin steckt. Und das ist dann sozusagen ihre elektrische Auslösung, wenn du es ziehst.
Bei manchen Schlösser ja auch relativ leicht aus. Da gibt es ja auch so schöne Videos im Netz, wie man das aufbekommt.
Ja, gibt's ja auch sehr schöne Videos im Netz. Auf LugosTV. Genau, von TheKey.
Genau, könnte sein. Irgendwann mal kursiert. Ich hab das jetzt nicht mit irgendjemanden gemacht.
Ja, das war in Holland, da war ich auch live dabei. Da warst du wahrscheinlich noch beeindruckt als ich. Ich war insofern nicht mehr beeindruckt, weil ich ihn gut kenne. Er ist einfach TheKey. Er heißt nicht ohne Grund so. Und er ist irgendwie der Chef der holländischen Lockpicker. Und von daher einfach sowieso nicht aufzuhalten.
Aber die Einfachheit war doch beeindruckend, oder?
Mit dem Kern einer Klopapierrolle. Mit dem Karton eines Kerns der Klopapierrolle. Das war sozusagen die Konsistenz, die er gesucht hat. Er hatte sich ein kleines Stückchen rausgeschnitten, hat es mit Thesafilm wiederum zusammengeklebt, dass es so ein kleines Röllchen war. Und zwar genau mit dem Durchmesser dieser kennsinken Dinger. Und der Effekt, den er erzielen wollte, der dann auch funktioniert hat, ist, dass wenn du das dann reinsteckst und so ein bisschen rumwuppelst, franzt natürlich dieser Karton auch so ein bisschen aus und ist griffig. Und nur mit Gefühl und diesem etwas Karton hat er einfach dieses Kennsinken-Lock aufgemacht. Weil einfach da diese kleinen Kügelchen, die da drin sind, die werden dann einfach mitgenommen und das reicht.
Das Schloss war dann auch nicht mal beschädigt. Das heißt, man kann auch die Gemeinheit tun.
Für die eventuelle Versicherung, ob das Ding zurückliegt. Gewaltfreies Öffnen von Schlossern.
So sieht's aus. Also ich würde da nicht so sehr viel drauf geben. Das ist natürlich ganz okay, wenn man so ein Ding immer dabei hat. Und wenn man mal irgendwo ist, wo man nicht so richtig weiß. Man will es einfach ein bisschen mehr sichern. Ich würde sagen, es hilft eher so gegen Leute. Es hilft dagegen, dass jemand es irgendwo anders hinstellt, als man es jetzt haben will. Aber Leute, die es jetzt nicht unbedingt klauen würden. Aber dass man einfach klarmacht, das soll jetzt hier wirklich stehen bleiben. Bitte nicht bewegen.
Zu den einfachen Diebstahlgefühlen.
Aber einen Diebstahlschutz ist das nicht wirklich. Jetzt gucken wir nochmal hier kurz, was die Specks eigentlich sagen. Ich bin mir nämlich jetzt auch gerade etwas unsicher, ob das Ding das hat. Was ist denn hier mit diesen Speckseiten irgendwie los?
Auf einmal bei Apple sieht es ja ganz anders aus. Hier ist auch noch eine Frage auf, die ist für Dennis vielleicht ganz interessant, wie groß die Unterschiede bei der Programmierung mit Coco Touch und Coco sind. Also ich hab schon welche festgestellt.
Na, das Foundation Framework, also NSString, NSDictionary, NSArray und so, das ist alles gleich. NSO, was es da nicht alles gibt. Das ist komplett übernommen, soweit ich das sehe. Und das andere heißt ja auf dem OS X AppKit. Das gibt es sozusagen gar nicht. Dafür gibt es das UI Kit, das User Interface Kit. Und dort sind ja einige Sachen neu, aber so Sachen wie Buttons natürlich sind auch gleich. Aber ein Table View ist schon anders auf dem iPhone.
Ich weiß jetzt konkret beim Webview, der heißt auf dem Desktop WebKit und heißt auf dem...
Das ist ja wieder nochmal ein extra Framework. Damit müssen wir mal gucken, was dabei ist.
Ich heiße auf dem iPhone UI Webview, also ist quasi ein Teil des Kerns. Und wird auch ein bisschen anders angesprochen. Aber ich glaube, man findet sich eigentlich relativ schnell mit dem einen zurecht, wenn man das andere hat. Was ich mich neulich gefragt habe, hat man eigentlich auf dem iPhone auch die mit diesem Objective-C2, hat man ja diese Garbage Collection?
Die hat man auf dem iPhone nicht.
Die hat man auf dem iPhone tatsächlich nicht. Ah, dann muss ich dieses ganze Release und Retain...
Garbage Collection ist zwar ganz cool, aber es kostet natürlich auch ein bisschen Zeit. Also Rechenleistung. Und die wollen sie auf dem iPhone einsparen, weil da haben sie ja nicht so viel.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das das Problem ist.
Ich glaube schon. Was denn sonst?
Was muss kurz erklärt werden? Garbage Collection bedeutet einfach, dass deine Programmiersprache in der Lage ist, für dich Speicher freizugeben, der von Variablen belegt wird, die du eigentlich nicht mehr brauchst.
Was eine unglaublich hilfreiche Sache ist.
Klar, das ist auch fast jede heutzutage.
Muss ich halt nicht mehr selber darum kümmern. Man besorgt sich ein Objekt, das belegt irgendwie 10 MB und das die Garbage Collection merkt, wenn man das Objekt nicht mehr braucht und auch nicht mehr darauf zugreifen kann. Und dann werden die 10 MB, sagen wir mal jetzt, als Beispiel wieder freigegeben.
Was man extrem gerne vergisst, das wieder freizugeben, dann hat man plötzlich ein Programm, was dann mal wieder, da mal 10 Kilobyte, sich da mal 10 Kilobyte dazuholt und...
Also das mit dem Speed, Dennis, das ist, Garbage Collection muss nicht langsam sein. Also das ist ein gelöstes Problem mittlerweile. Man hat Garbage Collection technisch so weit im Griff, dass Speed nicht das Hauptproblem ist. Es sei denn, du hast wirklich Realtime-Anforderungen, was ich jetzt beim iPhone so nicht sehen würde.
Aber warum haben sie es dann nicht auf dem iPhone?
Weil es natürlich auch die Speicherfreigabe delayed. Das heißt, es belegt sozusagen mehr Speicher, weil du ja diesen unbenutzten Speicher erstmal eine Weile vorhalten musst, bevor er dann auch wirklich freigegeben wird.
Aber eigentlich wissen sie doch beim Garbage Collection sofort, dass ich keinen Point mehr drauf hab, ist es weg.
Wenn du eine zirkuläre Liste hast, wo A zeigt auf B, auf C, auf D und Z zeigt wieder auf A.
Das kostet auch wieder CPU-Zeit.
Was?
Die aufzulösen, die gegenseitigen Abhängigkeiten.
Ja, aber die Algorithmen, die heutzutage gängig sind für Garbage Collection, können mit solchen Sachen, mit Mark und Sweep und was ich, was da für Methoden gibt, haben das ganz gut im Griff. Also ich kann dir das jetzt im Einzelnen nicht erklären, ich hab bloß immer mal wieder... Das ist in der Tat mal das schönes Thema für Chaos Radio Express. Wie auch immer, es kann auch beides sein. Es kann auch sein, dass es der Speed-Penalty ist und dass es auch der Buffer-Penalty ist, den du irgendwie brauchst, weil du muss ja...
Wahrscheinlich brauchst du entweder das eine oder das andere. Also entweder...
Genau, also auf dem System, wo man nicht einfach mit den Ressourcen so rumschweinern kann, wie auf dem iPhone, mag das nachvollziehbar sein. Vielleicht ist es auch nur so, dass sie das später einführen.
Aber noch als Tipp für dich als angehender Coco-Experte ist, wenn du ein Objekt allozierst, also mit ALOG INIT, dann musst du es releasen und ansonsten nicht.
Genau, das ist relativ...
Das ist eigentlich total easy. Alles andere ist nämlich auto-released für dich, da musst du dich gar nicht darum kümmern.
Es gibt immer die INIT-Methode, oder meistens die INIT-Methoden, bei denen muss ich es wieder releasen und bei den Strings from irgendwas zum Beispiel. Da hab ich keinen A-Log, da kann ich einfach so machen.
Kein A-Log, kein Release. Alles andere ist auto-released. Wenn du ein Copy machst von einem Objekt, musst du auch ein Release machen, weil du hast das ja neu gemacht. Und wenn du ein Objekt, so ein Auto-Release ist, wenn du es länger halten willst, als dein Event Loop geht, dann machst du ja ein Retain, dann musst du es auch releasen.
Oder ich schreibe einfach...
A-Log, Copy und Retain musst du mal releasen, sonst nicht. Das ist das Einzige, was man sich merken muss. Das sind die drei Dinge.
Genau, man muss dann denken. Das ist natürlich auch immer... Das ist bei mir so ein bisschen...
Ich gehe über mein Code immer drüber. Ich gucke ungefähr, wo ist ein A-Log. Nach einer Weile benutzt man gar nicht mehr so viele A-Logs. Weil meist ist eigentlich Auto-Release. Und dann sieht man ja gleich, alles klar, hier A-Log, und dann wieder freigeben. Und wenn man richtig faul ist, kann man ja A-Log machen und gleich ein Auto-Release hinten dran hängen, zur Not.
Ach so, ein Auto-Release, ja stimmt, den gibt es ja auch noch. Auto-Release ist, oh Gott, das hab ich jetzt nicht mehr so genau im Kopf.
Ja, das ist jetzt auch nicht so.
Vielleicht ist das ja auch der Grund, warum die Garbage Collection noch nicht drauf ist auf dem iPhone. So was braucht man ja tendenziell auch eher, wenn ein Programm wirklich ein bisschen länger läuft. Und, also dieses, dass der Speicher voll läuft. Und iPhone-Programme laufen ja im Allgemeinen gar nicht so lange, weil die...
Ja, aber eine Garbage Collection, die wirklich so funktioniert, dass du erst mal eine Stunde wartest, bis du anfängst, irgendwas wegzuschmeißt.
Nee, nicht bis man anfängt, was wegzuschmeißt, sondern bis wirklich Probleme aufgrund dessen auftreten, dass der Speicher nachher nachfolgt.
Weil die Programme relativ kurzlebig sind auf dem iPhone.
Ja, aber du willst ja auch den Speicher eigentlich sofort re-usen.
Aber die haben da schon, wenn ich ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen erzählen darf, auf dem iPhone, die haben da schon Techniken, wie sie ihren Speicher re-usen. Also wenn du, du hast ja ein Table-View auf dem iPhone, das ist das, wie zum Beispiel das Mail-Programm angezeigt wird, immer mit diesen Listen. Also Table-View halt. Und jede einzelne Eintrag ist eine sogenannte Zelle. NS-Table-View-Zelle. Und es ist so, dass du setzt da wieder ein Text rein. Und die Zellen, die aus der Anzeige verschwinden, die werden ja wieder freigegeben vom System. Und wenn du unten die neuen Zellen, die reinrutschen, die musst du ja wieder dir neu holen. Und dann werden die, du holst die nicht, also erzeugst keine neuen, sondern du fragst die Table View, hast du noch unbenutzte Zellen für mich? Also wieder frei geworden, die kriegen auch einen Identifier, damit du auch verschiedene haben kannst und nicht die falsche erwischt. Und dann kannst du wieder neu einsetzen bei einem Objekt. Neu verzweigen oder zu allozieren, den Speicher und alles wieder einzurichten, dauert länger, als nur zwei, drei Werte umzuschreiben. Und so machen die das beim iPhone. Das gibt es unter Leopard nicht, auf dem iPhone geht das so. Also sie haben da schon ein bisschen nachgedacht.
Der Chat fragt sich gerade, ob du jetzt gegen das fucking NDA verstoßen hast.
Also theoretisch ja, praktisch ne. Weil Apple ist nicht in der Lage, meinen Account freizuschalten. So gesehen kann das ja auch noch nicht. Da geht ja erst mit Bezahlung los. Das ist ja wie bei der Versicherung, oder?
Ach, sollen sie doch kommen, wir haben keine Angst. Wir haben keine Angst. Kommt doch! Also Dennis und Trim haben keine Angst. Ja, fucking Andy, ey, dein letzter Tag ist gekommen.
Also, ich hoffe mal, es gibt wohl auch, ich kenne niemanden, keinen Entwickler, der nicht in erster Linie sagt, Objective-C und Coco ist toll und der NDA ist die größte Scheiße überhaupt. So, da liegt er.
Ja, aber das hatten wir nun schon alles. Wir müssen einfach gucken, wie sich das entwickelt. So, wollen wir weiter nochmal Ihren Blog forschen? Also, hier wird gefragt, ob wir heutzutage noch Server-Side-Includes einsetzen würden. Ich glaube, ich habe das noch nie eingesetzt. Das ist ja jetzt wirklich überhaupt nicht Mac-spezifisch, aber kurze Antwort, nö, weil heutzutage nimmt man...
Aber heutzutage nimmt man nicht mehr... Heutzutage nimmt man... Easy heißt das.
Easy?
Easy. Heißt das Easy? Ich glaube schon. Ihr müsst jetzt mal schnell bei Vicky Easy gucken. E-S-I.
E-S-I.
Ja, und zwar... Ich hab mal eine Weile den Varnish, oder ich benutze ihn immer noch für eine Firma. Das ist so ein Beschleuniger. Also so ein Reverse-Proxy, der deine Webseite beschleunigt. Und zwar richtig hardcore, so von zwei Freebies, der Jungs programmiert.
Edge-Sites include.
Genau. Und der kann auch easy, da kannst du halt so ein HTML-Tag in deine Seite machen. Und der Warnisch holt sich diesen Tag raus, lädt die Adresse nach, fügt die ein und kann ausliefern und dadurch kann er beide unabhängig voneinander cashen.
Jetzt sollten wir erstmal erklären, was Serverside Includes sind. Also Serverside Includes ist eine ganz alte Technik vom Web-Server, wo man quasi in seine Webseiten, die man auf dem Server liegen hat, sagt, so und an dieser Stelle fügst du den Inhalt ein von...
Dokument X, Upset.
Von einem anderen Dokument. Und da kann man auch, glaube ich, irgendwie, könnte man auch irgendwie Programme reinwerfen, oder wie?
Da konnte man auch CGI's reinschmeißen, ab einigen Wissenpunkten. Die einfachste Variante ist, ich hab eine Seite, der Buddy ist immer der gleiche, oben hab ich aber eine Navigation drüber. Die Navigation will ich jetzt natürlich nicht in jeder einzelnen Seite einbauen, also mach ich das per SSI. Das war so die ganz alte Variante. Und das hat sich natürlich ein bisschen dadurch erledigt, dass es heutzutage, dafür nimmt man ein Content-Management-System, vermutlich, irgendwie auf PHP-Basis oder auf whatever und braucht damit keine SSIs mehr. Nun ist es aber natürlich so, dass SSIs sind zumindest in der Theorie ziemlich schnell. Das heißt, wenn ich wirklich einen Server hätte, der massiv unter Last steht und wo ich aber PHP nicht brauche, würde ich vorher noch mal einen Benchmark laufen lassen und mal gucken.
Ich verstehe, wenn es wirklich was ganz einfaches ist.
Wenn es was super einfaches ist. Also zum Beispiel jetzt ganz konkret bei Edwin Werbung bei meinem kleinen Twitter Client fürs iPhone, der webbasiert ist und erst mal eine ganze Weile noch webbasiert bleiben wird übrigens. Da habe ich eine HTML-Datei, die aufgerufen wird und es wird direkt in die Datei reingepackt, inkludiert in eine JavaScript-Datei. Inkludiert wird sie darum, damit man...
Das heißt, mit jedem Request wird aber auch das JavaScript gestartet?
Mit jedem Request wird auch das... Ne, es wird nur reingeladen und dann beim Browser seitlich ausgeführt. Das kann ich jetzt per PHP machen, indem ich einen Include mache oder sowas. Aber das kann ich natürlich auch per Server-Site Include machen. Und bisher mache ich es faul, wie ich bin, per PHP. Aber wenn der Server mal unter Last stehen sollte, dann werde ich mir das mal sehr genau angucken. Und der Vorteil davon für mich ist, dass ich meine JavaScript-Datei in einem JavaScript-Editor editieren kann und nicht mit einem, nicht blöd, einem HTML-Code rumfuseln muss.
Also für langsame Server und spezielle Webseiten mag das durchaus ein Ding sein, aber es hängt extrem von der Anwendung ab. Also das kann man nicht sehr generell sagen. Aber wenn man so ein Embedded Device hat, zum Beispiel wo ein Webserver drauf läuft, der ein bisschen Intelligenz mitbringen soll, der kein PHP stemmen kann, dann ist das auch schon eine Ausdaueration.
Oder wenn das Server richtig schön unter Niesalast steht.
Ich hab halt diesen Warnisch, und der sollte halt eigentlich Werbung einblenden. Der macht das jetzt zwar auf eine andere Methode, aber eine schicke Methode wäre eigentlich, dass es easy die Werbetext irgendwie da drin findet und sich dann vom Werbeserver, der auch ganz woanders stehen könnte, den Inhalt holt und dann da einpackt. Und dadurch, dass der Warnisch sich einzeln die Texts vollfüllt, kann er dann die Request auch einzeln cashen und muss die dann eventuell gar nicht holen.
Fullspeed Reverse Proxy.
Was ist das? Fullspeed Reverse Proxy?
Also Fullspeed heißt der ist einfach total schnell, ultraoptimiert, also weiß schon richtig. Flutscht wie nix und die haben auch Support.
Reverse Proxy heißt?
Na, normaler Proxy ist so wie Squid, wenn deine Web-Anfragen irgendwie von deinem Safari, in unserem Fall irgendwie beschleunigt werden, weil es eventuell schon im Cash liegt. Das machen Firmen, um Traffic zu sparen. Man kann es aber auch umdrehen und kann so ein Proxy vor so einem Apache davor hängen, vor so einem Web-Server, damit der Apache entlastet wird, weil da halt schon zum Beispiel das JavaScript, das PHP, das weiß, was ich nicht läuft, das ist halt viel zu langsam für Tausende von Anfragen die Sekunde. Also setzt man Warnisch davor, der cached ordentlich. Den kann man auch programmieren mit so einer geilen Programmiersprache, die dann im Programm läuft, also es wird nicht mal interpretiert, sondern direkt sozusagen. Und der ist halt ultra schnell und cached, das ist dann der reverse proxy. Cached sozusagen von der anderen Seite. Und der kann halt auch easy.
Also ein normaler Proxy, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ein normaler Proxy steht beim Provider.
Oder bei dir zuhause. Oder bei dir zuhause, klar. Aber du kannst auch einen von dem Provider nehmen.
Ja, aber vorne steht er bei meinem Provider und macht mir das Internet verfügbar.
Genau, das Gesamte.
Und ein reverse proxy kriege ich gar nicht mit, wenn ein Anbieter das anbietet, sondern einfach wenn ich auf dessen Dienste zugreifen will, hat der dann ein Proxy stehen damit, dass für seine Infrastruktur alles besser funktioniert.
Ich suche brandaktuell, also Green Man X. Man muss schon das so vorlesen, dass jeder auch weiß, was ich vorlese, ne? Also die Frage im Blog, die nächste von Green Man X ist, ich hab mir neulich mal eine Sendung von uns angehört und da ist mir das aufgefallen, dass wir einfach so anfangen, dann irgendwie vorzulesen und man hört ja gar nicht. Man hört ja nicht, dass man gerade was vorlesen...
Ich kann das Ganze auch mal wieder reden.
Reden, reden, reden und immerhin höherer.
Tim begibt sich in eine Lesehaltung. Langsam.
Ich kann auch so eine Zen-artige Bodaiske...
Und er bereitet sich innerlich auf das Lesen vor. Wir können seine Gedanken nur erahnen. Aber er fängt jetzt mit Lesen an.
GreenManX sagt, ich suche brandaktuell zum Hören eures Livestreams eine Alternative zu iTunes slash AirTunes. Ich würde eure Sendung gerne auf die HiFi-Anlage streamen, aber iTunes kann AFAIK den Stream nicht abspielen. Also, erstens stimmt das nicht, weil wir senden hier einen MP3 und das geht sehr wohl mit iTunes.
Geht das auch anders als mit der iTunes?
Ja, aber kann man es auch über das, wie auch immer das Protokoll heißt, zu seiner AirPod Express schicken. Das meint er wohl.
Kann man?
Ich hab letztens mal probiert und dann ging das nicht.
Doch, also ich hör eigentlich immer so Radio, HTTP-Streaming und dann verteile ich das hier in jedem Raum in der Wohnung mit...
Achso, nee, was ich probiert hab, war mit Front-Raw. Ich wollte auch Front-Raw schicken, vom Sofa, wie meine Musik steuern, dachte, das ist klatschig, ich schicke zu meiner Express rüber an die Anlage. Ja, bei Front-Raw kannst du dann Express nicht auswählen.
Front-Raw macht das nicht und Apple TV macht das auch nicht.
Wir können ja gar nichts mehr Apple TV.
Das ist ja noch schlechter als Apple TV. Wenn sie das könnten, hätte ich wahrscheinlich sogar schon eine gekauft, weil dann hätte ich endlich mal so ein Standalone-User-Interface, wo ich das übertragen kann.
Weil das Remote-Programm auf dem iPhone zum Beispiel, das kann wiederum den Source auswählen und dann auch die AirPod Express, das geht.
Apple TV kann es andersrum, du kannst Apple TV ansprechen, wie eine Express. Du kannst da zur Anlage was hinschicken.
Oder zum Fernseher in dem Fall.
Genau, das ist sozusagen die Idee, dass du da deine Hi-Fi-Anlage dran hast, aber dass du es überall hören willst, und den Fernseher nur als User-Interface-Screen benutzt, das hat sich bei denen irgendwie nicht so manifestiert.
Wir können auch die Frage jetzt beantworten, ob wir es schaffen werden, vor Chaos Radio fertig zu sein.
Nein, wir schaffen es. Ihr müsst jetzt bei uns bleiben, Jungs. Wie auch immer. Irgendwas werdet ihr per Podcast hören, oder irgendwas verpassen. Aber ich frage mich jetzt, was der Grund jetzt für seine Frage sein könnte, weil Hermeint, iTunes kann sich abspielen. Vielleicht ist es einfach nur ein Missverständnis. Kannst du. Solltest du auf jeden Fall können. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, warum es nicht geht. Grundsätzlich ist aber die Frage nach Alternativen dazu ganz gut, weil, na gut, R-Tunes, blödsinn, hier, R-Foil. Das wäre sozusagen die Antwort. Ihr wisst, was ich meine, von Rogue Armöber, die diese Audio-Spitze ist.
Wir wissen schon, was du meinst. Unser Hörer weiß nicht, was du meinst.
R-Foil ist von Rogue Armöber, die ja so totale Audiospitzis sind, die auch so geile Sachen wie dieses Audio-Hijack Pro machen. Benutz ich, bin ich Kunde.
Und die ein geiles Alken haben von so einer bösen Armöbe.
Genau, die einfach total cool sind. Und die auch eben dieses Protokoll gehackt haben, mit dem man jedes beliebige Programm und jeden beliebigen System Soundkanal umleiten kann auf Airpod Express. Ja, da sind sie auch echt gut drin.
Und muss man dazu sagen, was das große Ding ist, seit irgendeiner Version, habe ich schon vor Monaten gelesen, sie können auch halt, du kannst den Film anschauen und können die Audiospur von dem Film zu deiner Express schicken, was das iTunes nicht kann.
For no reason.
Ja, weil ich habe mich auch schon früher festgestellt, dass ja auch jede Express hatte ja irgendwie einen Timedemon drin, einen NTP, also das auf jeden Fall die perfekte Uhrzeit drin hat. Dadurch könnte man prima sünden, weil jedes Gerät selber wüsste...
Ja, sie sünden ja auch, sie senden ja an mehrere Airpodexpresse und spielen gleichzeitig auf dem Computer ab.
Das auch noch inzwischen, genau. Also, das wäre alles gar kein Ding. Das wäre der Hit.
Das wäre der Hit und ich weiß auch überhaupt nicht, was das soll. Und das dann auch gleich mal auf die Apple TV. Dass man Filme anzeigen kann und man kann den Sound auch in der Küche spielen. Weil das ist genau der Vorteil. Also, wenn ich so eine, was weiß ich, wenn ich jetzt live Chaos-Radio höre, was ich jetzt nicht tue, weil ich gerade selber podcaste...
Wir können ja eine Live-Schaltung machen.
Und ich alleine bin in meiner Wohnung, dann setze ich das einfach auf jeden Raum und dann kann ich mich einfach frei bewegen.
Dann wirst du mit Unterhosen durch die Wohnung und hörst dabei das Chaos-Radio.
Ach, das geht nicht mit Unterhosen.
Aber für die Leute, die jetzt so WMV-Streams und so weiter oder andere komplexe Sachen oder OX-Streams hören wollen und AirPod Express benutzen wollen, Airfoil von Rogue Amoeba ist euer Ding.
Aber ich glaube, manchmal liegt sowas bei Apple auch daran, dass irgendjemand, und ich vermute mal Steve Jobs, das Interesse an so Dingen einfach mal verliert. Ich glaube, der ist auch so ein bisschen so... Den einen Tag war dafkall total... Alle haben gesagt, hey, wir müssen dafkall machen.
Der macht doch auch nicht mehr alles alleine. Das geht gar nicht.
Nee, der macht das nicht alleine, aber ich glaube, er hat da immer noch die fettige, die Hände sehr stark drauf, was jetzt gerade wie hohe Priorität hat. Und wenn dann irgendjemand kommt und sagt, hallo, wir würden gerne mal bei dem AirPod Express streamen und wir haben jetzt keine Zeit für, dann macht man lieber Bug-Fixing mit dem iPhone.
Ich würde gerne von euch wissen, ob ihr schon Näheres über die Funktionsweise von der Grand Central Technologie im kommenden Schneeleo wisst. Na ja, wir haben ja eben schon beklagt. Es gibt eigentlich wenig Neues. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das letzte Mal eigentlich da groß drüber unterhalten haben. Na, ist schon ein paar Sendungen her.
Da war es noch. Früher konnten wir noch ein bisschen was von der WWDC erzählen, aber inzwischen weiß ich auch schon wieder nicht mehr so genau. Das wäre jetzt wirklich Wischiwaschi, was wir jetzt erzählen würden.
Da können wir nur Wischiwaschi noch hinzufügen.
Und das sollen wir ja nicht machen.
Und das sollen wir ja nicht machen? Und, keine Ahnung. Aber irgendwas war doch noch mal mit threading. Ach ja, genau. Ich bin ja bei dieser ganzen Prozessor-News-Geschichte nicht so firm, aber Intel hat doch einen neuen Prozessor vorgestellt, wo sie sich darüber ausschweigen, wie viele Cores sie da tatsächlich drin haben werden.
Haben sie?
Ich gerade in meinem...
Das ist doch gerade das EDF, Intel Developer Forum, oder was?
Stimmt.
Was heißt das EDF? Das heißt glaube ich was anderes.
Ich glaube es heißt Intel Developer Forum, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher. Wir besitzen Google. Wir besitzen Hörer.
Was will sie hinaus?
Worauf will ich hinaus?
International Diabetes Federation. Da müssen wir abspecken.
Israel Defense Force. Es ist das Intel Developer Forum.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall.
Die Vermutung.
Sagen wir mal, Intel würde einen Prozessor rausbringen, der 16 oder 32 Cores hat. Weil mit 16 rechnen wir irgendwie alle, weil 8 gibt's schon. Das sei denn jetzt für Laptop natürlich. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob so ein Laptop Prozessor geht. Mac Pro.
Das sind 2x4.
Oh, stimmt.
Du hast da wohl deine Insider-Quellen.
Na, was ja kommen soll für die 6-fachen irgendwie im nächsten Jahr. Und 8-fach haben sie, glaube ich, gerade heute berichtet, kommen so in 2, 3 Jahren oder so was.
Okay, was auf jeden Fall klar ist, ist, die ganze Prozessorenentwicklung geht gerade in Richtung zu mehr Cores. Und keiner hat eigentlich, software-technisch, da wirklich schon so eine gute Antwort, wie man diese Cores auch nutzen kann. Das heißt, dieses Leistung des Rechners nimmt zu. Funktioniert ja nicht mehr so einfach wie damals mit dem Gigahertz, wo doppelt so viel Gigahertz, doppelt so viel Performance in einem Programm. Jetzt musst du halt ganz anders programmieren, um das zu nutzen. Und auch beliebig viele Cores bringen, auch bei beliebig viel, bei beliebig parallelisierbaren Programmen auch nicht unbedingt immer den entsprechenden Faktor. Das weiß ich, Photoshop kann sicherlich in vielen seiner Funktionen mehrere Cores auch gleichzeitig nutzen. Wenn du einen Filter anwendest und so weiter.
Jede Video-Applikation.
Ja, aber es ist eben auch irgendwo ein Overhead zu synchronisieren.
Man muss es auch verwalten.
Dieser Overhead, genau, dieser Overhead wirkt mit und vor allem, er ist komplex und es macht eben dann Programme auch Fehlanverlierungen. Meine Theorie ist, dass das Grand Central vor allem da ansetzt, eben das Nutzen mehrerer Prozessoren zu vereinfachen. Gut, das ist eigentlich naheliegend und so wird es ja auch offiziell beschrieben. Und ich denke, dass es gar nicht wertvoll ist, darüber groß nachzudenken, wie das im Einzelnen funktioniert, weil es wird einfach genau das sein. Programme, die für Grand Central programmieren, werden es einfacher haben zu skalieren, sobald die Prozessoren mehr kosten.
Wir können da Jobs schicken, das Grand Central verteilt, die wie ein großer Bahnhof halten, deswegen heißt das Ding ja so, weil Grand Central Station ist der große Bahnhof von New York, wenn ich das richtig sehe, richtig? Und so läuft die Sache. Da gibt es aber noch eine andere Sache, warte kurz, in GCC 4.0 oder ab 4.2, ich glaube ab 4.2 gibt es das sogenannte OpenMP, heißt das so? Das ist ja wischiwaschi, das ist schlimm. Aber ich kann mir nicht mal das perfekt merken, es ist halt immer so. Und dort gibt es in C-Code Erweiterungen, die sind wahrscheinlich GCC spezifisch, aber ok, wenn es OpenMP ist, ist das Standard, schon wieder wischiwaschi, ist egal. Jedenfalls angenommen, du hast eine Schleife mit 10.000 Durchgängen, ist ja der Iterator, dann kannst du da so Kommandos angeben oder Zusatzinformationen für den Compiler, dass du sagst, ok, diese 10.000, das soll gesthreadet werden, folgende Variablen sind fix, folgende irgendwie nicht, dann musst du dich irgendwie mit den Prozessen drum streiten. Oder Prozess 1. Und dann kann er die 10.000 Iterationen, kann er irgendwie sagen, du hast 16 CPUs, macht da 10.000 so wie 16 und verteilt es an die einzelnen CPUs und am Ende wartet er, bis alle einzeln fertig sind und du musst dich da nicht mehr drum kümmern, sondern der Compiler erzeugt Code, der sich dann später skalieren lässt.
Abhängigkeiten erkennen und Synchronisationen durchführen, das ist so im Wesentlichen das, was so ein Framework zu leisten hat.
Genau, das macht dieses Open-App. Du musst aber schon noch ein bisschen Zusatzinfos angeben, also dass du sagst, hier der Editorator, den kannst du ausblitten, diese Werte hier, die sind immer gleich pro Prozessor und das Ergebnis hier musst du von allen CPUs halt trotzdem immer aufadieren und so weiter und so fort. Und da wird sie schon ein bisschen was tun. Ist natürlich klar, dass die Software von heute auf morgen kann es nicht umschreiben oder nicht so viel machen, aber ich denke mal bei Photoshop von Adobe war es ja auch schon mal so, dass das Programm selbst, so das GUI, da muss ich ja nichts ändern, sondern es sind ja die ganzen Plugins und Module, die sie haben, so Blur und Zeug und was es da alles so gibt. Und die werden ja im Wesentlichen angepasst und ich denke mal, das ist gar nicht so schwer. Also die, die am meisten Saft verbrauchen, werden die glaube ich schon ganz schnell anpassen. Das war ja bei Intel auch schon so ein Intel irgendwie mit hier MMX und SSE und so weiter raus kamen. Haben die auch immer gleich mit Adobe und anderen großen Buden zusammen gearbeitet und haben dann immer die fettesten Blur-Module irgendwie, ja guckt man so schnell, das ist jetzt dank MMX und SSE.
Das waren aber auch dann die einzigen, die mitgezogen haben und die anderen hatten alle so ihre Schlechtkeiten.
Wie sieht denn das eigentlich aus?
Das sind auch die Programme, die es brauchen. Also was braucht es denn? Das Twitter-Ding braucht nicht irgendwie Multi-CPU-Kram. So langsam ist es einfach nicht. Es sind halt nur die fetten Programme.
Na gut, aber wenn Apple schnellere Computer verkaufen will, müssen sie dafür sorgen, dass nahezu jedes Programm was davon hat.
Web-Browser werden in Zukunft das zentrale Problem sein, glaube ich, wie die unglaublich viele Prozessoren brauchen werden, dass Flash auf mehreren Prozessoren läuft und so was.
Du bist der Untergang der Menschheit, Max.
Wie viele Tabs ich da offen habe?
Ja genau, weil du so ein Web-Freak bist. Die müssen weg von diesem Shit.
Von Web? Wieso das denn?
Weil es esackt einfach. Dein Rechner leer.
Ja, soll es doch, weil ich es so gerne nutze.
Das webb nicht, das flash.
Das webb auch diese Animated Gifts, die irgendwie nichts bringen oder falsch gemacht sind. Und alles flimmert und flattert.
Animated Gifts bringen deinen Computer definitiv nicht in die Knie.
Nicht mehr?
Also zumindest nicht nennenswert. Skripting, JavaScript, da würde ich dir jederzeit zustimmen, aber das jetzt dem webb vorzuwerfen, das ist egal. Das webb ist eigentlich nur eine andere Delivery-Methode. So, weiter geht's im Text.
Aber gibt's nicht...
Weiter geht's im Text oder geht's nicht weiter im Text?
Es geht noch nicht ganz weiter im Text, weil ich wollte noch ganz kurz was ansprechen. Bei der Playstation 3, die müssten doch mittlerweile wissen, wie man für extrem viele Prozessorkerne programmiert. Weißt du denn, Dennis, ein bisschen mehr, wie das da abläuft? Nee.
Weil die haben doch diese sieben Zellprozessoren.
Und das müsste doch eigentlich, die müssten auch dann mit, also acht haben sie, sieben nutzen sie.
Kann ich wieder auf ein Chaos Radio Express Podcast verweisen? Nummer 89 über Computerspiele.
Du weißt die Nummern ausfindig. Und da geht es auch um den Zellprozessor?
Da kommt das zur Sprache. Das ist nämlich ein echtes Problem für Sony, die Spielerentwickler da zuzubekommen. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass sie das alle nicht hinkriegen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein anerkanntes Problem. Sie haben da schon auch ein neues Programmiermodell zu vermitteln mit diesem Zellprozessor, der ja im Prinzip genau auf dieser Idee der hohlen Parallelisierbarkeit basiert. Aber Parallelisierbarkeit ist eben etwas, das muss auch gekonnt werden. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, inwieweit Sony auf der Plattform solche Subsysteme bietet wie Grand Central oder OpenMP. Also irgendwas werden sie da sicherlich bieten. Ich erinnere mich jetzt nur, im Podcast kam das zur Sprache und das ist halt auch ein Problem und das ist ein Vorteil für die Xbox. Also zumindest hat es mein Gast, der Todd Weidemann, der es hier ganz gut auskennt, so gedeutet. Und ich denke, dass diese Probleme bei Apple auch sehr bekannt sind. Weil ich erinnere, es gab schon vor sehr langer Zeit, und die ist jetzt schon richtig lange her, das ist schon über zehn Jahre, da gab es ja schon mal eine Multiprozessormaschine von Apple.
Genau, die hatte zweimal 300 Megahertz, glaube ich.
Genau, und das waren auch diese 604er Prozessoren.
604e.
604e Prozessoren. Das war ein Ladenhüter, weil die haben natürlich mehr gekostet, weil da noch mal ein ganzer Prozessor mit drin war.
Aber eben gab es keine mehr davon. Die waren voll super für so einen Hacker.
Na ja, klar, aber es hat den Anwendern nichts gebracht.
Genau, das OS hat das gar nichts genutzt.
Es gab ein Photoshop-Plugin, was das Ganze gemacht hat.
Es gab ein Photoshop-Plugin und vielleicht noch eins für Premiere und das war's aber auch schon.
Und dann haben auch nur die Plugins, nicht die Software selber usw. Also es ist einfach, Sie haben sich wahrscheinlich gedacht, dass allein Ihr Fotomarkt da schon genug reißt und dass die Leute, die Photoshop-Plugin...
Da gab es noch Clones von Daystar, stimmt's? Mit 8-fach sogar. Oder 4-fach?
Das war eine Zeit lang so, dass dann Apple das Ding abgeschafft hat und dass dann die einzige Multi-Prozessor-Maschine mit Mac OS drauf, konnte man nicht von Apple bekommen.
Die hießen Daystar, glaube ich. Gab Daystar? 4-fach war es nicht, 8-fach. 4x250, die hatten sozusagen 1 Gigabit. Wahnsinn. Und keiner konnte was damit anfangen.
Nicht wirklich.
Außer Distributed Net.
Aber okay.
Wie man mit diesen ganzen Clones nichts anfangen konnte.
Ich hatte mal einen und war mit dem halb...
Ja, aber es hat natürlich die Reform.
Okay, aber die Zukunft ist auf jeden Fall, um es noch mal kurz zu fassen, die Zukunft ist irgendwie...
Naja, hat er recht.
Naja, schon.
Die Vergabe des Multimedia.
Aber ich meine, guck mal, du hast hier in Objectis hier, sind wir wieder bei Max Cocores Cocore Ambition. Wenn du auch da einen Array hast, sagen wir auch, 10.000 groß, und du willst es sortieren, kannst du auch mit Quick Sort das schnell in zwei Hälften teilen und danach könnten das auch gleich die Prozessoren irgendwie einzeln übernehmen. Aber ich denke nicht, dass es schon so gemacht wird. Aber man könnte es eigentlich easy so machen. So mit schönen High-Level-Languages geht das doch alles. Also da muss ich ja gar nichts machen als Programmierer, sondern das kann ja das System unten drunter für mich tun.
Klar, es gibt ja auch Programmiersprachen, die grundsätzlich Unterstützung haben für hochgradig parallelisierbare Vorgänge. Zum Beispiel R-Lang. Dann gibt es auch noch andere Beispiele, von denen wir natürlich jetzt gerade keine einfache... Ach ja, XSLT zum Beispiel. Die sind sich theoretisch auch sehr gut parallelisieren. Ja klar, also wenn du auch immer die Dependencies und die Seiteneffekte ausschließen kannst, in dem Moment kannst du parallelisieren. Und das ist aber schwierig. Also es ist nicht trivial und die Optimierung, die man eben erreichen kann, durch das Betrachten entweder von Sourcecode oder den Betrachten der Laufzeit oder den Betrachten des Linkzustandes usw. Das ist halt das, das ist das, woran gerade gearbeitet wird. Hat man ja nun auch schon mehrfach hier in der einen oder anderen Form auf dem Tisch. Wollen wir weiter?
Coolste ist, wenn ich mich als Programmierer nicht kümmern müsste um sowas.
Wäre toll, aber ich glaube, da sind wir schon noch ein bisschen weiter weg. Mal gucken, vielleicht sind wir mit Schneeleo dann schon klüger. So, hier, was gibt das Blog noch her? Hier wird noch viel gefragt. Vorausgesetzt, Mobile Me funktioniert ab Weihnachten. Was würdet ihr bevorzugen? Mobile Me oder Mac OS Server auf einem Mac Mini? Deine Antwort kenn ich denn, Dennis. Na, du würdest einen Mac OS Server auf einem Mac Mini bevorzugen.
Stimmt. Ich wusste erst mal nicht, was ich mit dem Server so anfangen soll.
Naja, es geht ja hier um die Realisierung von so Push, also von Internet-basierten Dienst.
Also ich mach mein Shit gerne selber und will meine E-Mails nicht unbedingt bei anderen Leuten haben.
Aber ob Mac OS Server das bietet, was Mobile Me bietet, das...
Natürlich nicht, weil sie mit Mobile Me auf lange Sicht natürlich mehr verdienen als mit dem Mac OS Server.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite sind das auch ganz andere Kundenkreise. Ich meine, sie brauchen ja zum Beispiel Web Apps und so weiter. Hättest du dann nicht? Dieser ganze, ich lese meine Mail im Netz, das ist ja auch ein wichtiger Teil von Mobile Me, der uns überhaupt nicht interessiert. Ja, viele Leute, aber uns nicht so.
Aber es könnte das Web, wie Quatsch hier, wie heißt das, OS 10 Server auch bieten.
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie das da reintun werden und ich glaube auch nicht, dass es das ist, wonach ich fragen würde, sondern ich will eigentlich nur diese Sync-Dienste haben, die einfach so funktionieren. Ich will einfach nur die Geräte gesynct haben. Ich kaufe mir auch gerne mehrere.
Aber du meinst, das muss nicht über Apple gehen, sondern die können sich so Sync, oder was?
Ich will nicht einen Server benutzen, dem ich nicht vertrauen kann. Oder zumindest von dem ich weiß, wie sehr ich ihm vertrauen kann, weil ich ihn selber administriere. Da weiß ich, dass ich ihm nicht vertrauen kann und kriege nicht die Illusion von einem, dem ich vertrauen könnte. Ja, Frage beantwortet, oder? Jetzt kommt hier genau die Intel Prozessoren-Frage. Das kann man noch nicht beantworten. Was haltet ihr von Intel Strategien mit dem Larabee-Chip als Grafikkarte alle Geschwindigkeitsprobleme mit der Anzahl von Prozessorkern zu erschlagen? Das ist, glaube ich, der Chip, von dem ich geredet habe. Larabee. Stimmt, das war auch noch in dem Kontext...
Ist es dieses neue Grafikprojekt, wo die auch schon Raytracing irgendwie vorgeführt haben auf diesem Chip? Ist es der?
Das kann gut sein, das weiß ich nicht genau. Aber der Punkt ist natürlich, darüber haben wir auch schon geredet bei dieser Parallelisierungsdebatte. Nicht wegen Grand Central, sondern wie ist noch gleich das andere Framework, was sie angekündigt haben für Schnee Leo, für Grafik? Genau, das greift ja ineinander. Also im Prinzip sind ja Grafikkarten einfach Maschinen mit Prozessoren, die hochgradig auf Parallelisierung optimiert sind.
Sehr speziell, aber scheiße schnell.
Genau, sehr speziell, aber scheiße schnell. Und die Prozessoren, die normalen, die Multipurpose Prozessoren, gehen halt aber auch jetzt in Multicore und halt auch diese Parallelisierung. Und eigentlich ist es schon sinnvoll, diese Entwicklung da mal so ganz holistisch anzugehen und zu sagen, was können wir von dem einen ins andere holen, was können wir von dem anderen ins eine holen. Und so wie man eben die Performance der Grafikkarte auch mal für Berechnungen nutzt, kann man natürlich auch sagen, warum nicht gleich das ganze Prozessordesign so öffnen und miteinander verzahnen, dass diese Funktionalitäten zusammenkommen. Da sind wir im Prinzip auch wieder bei diesem Core-Ding ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht. Das ist wirklich jetzt was für ein Prozessorexperten, der bin ich nicht, das sind glaube ich alle nicht. Was halten wir davon? Ich halte das für interessant. Also, mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Aber da muss ja auch mal schon wieder dickerer Content her, oder? Ich meine, ich kann mit meinem MacBook Pro locker so...
Das ist immer der gleiche, der fragt hier, Congo...
.HTTV-Film abspielen.
Bitte?
Also, da müsste ein neuer Content kommen, mehr Aufgaben, weil mein Rechner kann doch jetzt schon irgendwie HDTV-Film abspielen.
Dein Rechner idle? Na dann richte mal Time Machine ein, dann hat er wieder was zu tun.
Ja, da hilft dir dein Multicore auch nichts, das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen. Weil das ist nämlich, wo er die Platten-Io-Leistungen zusammen bricht und dann deswegen nichts mehr geht. Das hat nichts mit CPU-Performen zu tun.
Na ja, der denkt auf jeden Fall nach. Der lag auf jeden Fall an meinem User-Interface.
Der wartet auf die Platte, glaube ich. Man macht so viele einzelne Leaks.
Ja, aber meinetwegen kann er ja warten, aber er soll mich nicht vom Arbeiten abhalten. So, hier, Kongo hat viele Fragen und jetzt fragt er noch, ob sich das Warten auf den neuen NEA-Lamp-Prozessor in Bezug auf die Geschwindigkeit lohnt.
Warten lohnt nie.
Genau, das ist unsere Standard-Antwort.
Achso, dann behaupte ich einfach das Gegenteil. Warten lohnt immer.
Warum?
Keine Ahnung, weil ich...
Weil dann hast du keinen Computer. Dann hast du keinen Computer.
Und das wär ja manchmal gar nicht so.
Ich spule mal hier ein bisschen vor, ihr seid mit... Gibt es Mac-Emulatoren für die Windows-Welt? Ich hab ja auch gehört, er hätte mal was von PeerPC gehört.
PeerPC gab mal, aber es ist ewig lange her, das war noch für PowerPC Code. Glaub auch.
Aber eigentlich müsste es doch jetzt wieder easy sein.
Also mittlerweile gibt es ja diese, also gar nicht mehr Emulatoren.
Wieso? Aber es gibt doch VM-Ware, dann gibt es irgendwie gehackte US-Ten-Images, klar geht das. Also so wie du einen Hackintosh benutzen kannst, die einen basteln kannst, kannst du doch das gleiche Leopard-Image, was in deinem Hackintosh läuft, müsste dann auch in deiner VM-Ware laufen.
Ich hatte sogar mal eins am Laufen. In der VM-Ware war sagenhaft langsam, und zwar insbesondere wegen der Grafikgeschwindigkeit, weil Quartz Extreme nicht in VM-Ware läuft, weil VM-Ware das nicht unterstützt. Und das war überhaupt kein Spaß. Also es war schlicht und ergreifend nicht benutzbar. Insofern so richtig nein.
Hat der Apple wieder gefickt eingeschädelt. Also müsste gehen.
Also es geht irgendwie, aber es macht keinen Spaß.
Noch mal eine Zusatzfrage, weil es mich gerade mal interessiert. Da gab es doch irgendwas, dass Mac OS X Server jetzt auch in Parallels laufen würde und zwar offiziell. Kann da noch einer kurz was erzählen?
Apple erlaubt es in den Lizenzbedingungen von Mac OS X Server, dass es virtualisiert wird.
Und das funktioniert auch schon.
Ich glaube es gibt für VMware gibt es, unterstützt das mittlerweile offiziell. Hier VMware Fusion und zwar die 2er Beta irgendwas und Parallels glaube ich auch, aber möchte ich mich jetzt nicht zu weit aus dem Fernsehen legen.
Du kannst halt einfach mehrere Mac OS X Server auf Basis, also mit derselben, mit einer Lizenz kannst du das OS mehrfach auf deinem Server fahren.
Siehst du jetzt noch nicht so schnell erstmal den Sinn?
Na klar, du hast ja vollkommen separate Systeme. Du kannst halt einen Mail-Server aufsetzen und kannst einen Database-Server aufsetzen, die nichts miteinander zu tun haben. Wenn der eine braun ist, ist er braun, aber der andere läuft halt immer noch. Aber sie laufen halt beide auf derselben Hardware. Kann ich dir auch einen Chaos Radio Express empfehlen zu dem Thema?
Ach, geh doch weg.
Rein zufällig?
Nur noch ein Mobile Macs mit Empfehlungen rausgeben.
Na Entschuldigung, aber wenn du mehr wissen willst, ich hab eine schöne Sendung gemacht mit einem Xen-Entwickler, Xen-Entwickler, Entschuldigung, über Virtualisierung.
Virtualisierung ist ein spannendes Thema.
Chaos Radio Express 092, Virtualisierung.
Da hab ich das mal verstanden. Da wird bei FreeBSD ganz viel am Xen geschraubt. Die wollen wahrscheinlich einen Native Support haben jetzt.
Oh, das ist da schon Native.
In FreeBSD? Die machen da gerade ganz viel.
FreeBSD ist exklusiv bei Xen da auch unterstützt. Also du kannst es dafür benutzen.
Ich sollte ja noch was erzählen, dann kannst du ein bisschen da kurz mal weiter forschen. Ich sollte ein bisschen was erzählen zu ZFS. Natürlich hatten wir auch schon eine Chaos-Radio-Sendung, auf die muss man erstmal verweisen, weil das ist... Ach jetzt! Ich kann ja auch mal.
Das ist ja noch nicht so interessant.
Also das ist die Grundlage, die man sich anhören sollte, damit man erstmal so ein bisschen ZFS-Überblick hat. Ansonsten gibt es Neuigkeiten, weil ich versuche das immer so ein bisschen zu verfolgen. Auf FreeBSD hat der PAL vor zwei oder drei Wochen, weiß ich gar nicht so genau, einen dickeren, größeren Patch abgeliefert, sodass es jetzt wesentlich stabiler und schneller und auch in einer neueren Version auf FreeBSD läuft. Das ist leider noch nicht eingecheckt, aber es gibt einen Patch für Current, nicht für 7.0, sondern für 8.0 Current, wer sich da auskennt. Es läuft super wunderbar, hab ich zu Hause und auch...
Also Current ist die aktuelle Entwicklungsversion. Da wirst du dich auch noch eine Chaos Rally-Expressin auf die verweisen können, nämlich über FreeBSD. Mit Krüggs?
Ich weiß. Jedenfalls, da passiert einiges gerade. Ich warte, bis es dann auch mal wirklich eingecheckt wird, weil dieser Patch, ich find den ja doof, dass ich mal von Hand patchen muss. Dann die andere Sache ist, dass die zuständige Frau bei Apple ist, nämlich eine Frau, Noelle de la Fane, oder wie heißt sie, hab ich jetzt vergessen. Auf jeden Fall Noelle heißt sie. Die für ZFS dort zuständig ist, hat gesagt, dass sie auch an der neuesten Version B95, weil die bei Open Solar ist, von ZFS ja kommt, von Sun, immer ihre Versionen dadurch. Diese Version ist wohl auch gerade, sind sie dabei, auf den Mac anzupassen. Und dann ist auch das Mac OS X, wenn sie dann mal fertig, sie sind gerade dabei, auch dort sind wir dann auf dem neuesten Stand. Also gibt es dann so Features wie das... Na, booten ist theoretisch vom ZFS in dem, was die bei Mac OS haben, vom ZFS her schon der Support da, da musst du so ein Boot-Property setzen und so weiter, ich glaube das geht schon. Aber natürlich brauchst du ja noch den Bootloader, der das ZFS beherrscht, um das erstmal zu booten. Und den gibt es halt noch nicht. Also das ZFS selbst ist eigentlich schon so weit.
Also was ist denn dann in dieser neuesten Version jetzt drin, was jetzt in diesem ZFS, vor allem Mac OS X noch nicht drin ist?
Na zur Zeit haben sie, also die nummerieren halt immer durch, damit halt immer weiß, wann welches Feature irgendwie zur Verfügung steht, weil es muss ja auch kompatibel bleiben und so weiter. Und eine neue Version kann das ältere, aber die ältere kann halt irgendwie neueren Zeugs nicht. Und eine Sache ist zum Beispiel, die aktuelle Version ist 12, wobei es für 12 noch nicht mal Infos gibt, aber es ist schon, ich hab den Code schon gesehen.
Das ist die Version von ZFS oder was?
Also wenn du dir so einen Z-Pool erstellst und du machst es jetzt zum Beispiel mit dem allerneuesten FreeBSD, dann hast du erstmal noch Version 11. Und wenn du diese Platte dann nimmst und du kannst sie auch auf den Mac mounten, weil es ist ja untereinander kompatibel und so weiter, dann könnte dein Mac die aber nicht lesen, weil dein Mac bisher nur Version 8 unterstützt. Dann geht die da nicht ran, weil da sind halt Sachen gesetzt, die dein 8 nicht kennt, und dann geht der Sicherheitshalber da nicht ran, weil da könnte ja dabei was kaputt gehen, er ist halt zu alt, müsste es erst aufrüsten.
Das heißt, die aktuelle Version ist 8? Auf dem Mac. Auch mit diesem 1.1.9. Was man sich runterladen kann, damit man lesen und schreiben kann?
Das ist irgendwie Open Solaris gemäß Version 74.
Wie häufig ändern sich denn diese Versionen?
Es kommt immer ganz raus, es war mal wieder ein, zwei Monate nichts, und dann plötzlich haben sie irgendwie zwei Changes in einer Woche. Das kann halt immer mal so passieren.
Okay, ich wusste nicht, dass ZFS noch so ein Moving Target ist.
Weil sie immer neue Sachen dazuschreiben. Also zum Beispiel auch extra für Apple wurde Case Insensitivity.
Case Preserving.
Case Insensitivity, genau. Haben sie gemacht, oder dann die ACLs kamen irgendwie. Dann ist eine Version, dass du ein sogenanntes Cache Device dazu klatschen kannst. Jetzt müsst ihr ein bisschen Ahnung haben, wenn ihr euch einen RAID 5 macht. Auf dem ZFS heißt das ja RAID Z. Mit fünf Platten, da muss man immer von fünf Platten lesen, um dir die Information zu liefern, weil das ja so verteilt wird auf einen RAID Z. Und weil das eventuell ein bisschen langsam ist, oder weil deine Platten auch nicht gerade welche sind, die mit 15.000 Umdrehungen drehen, hast du eine relativ hohe Latenz, dass deine Daten irgendwie da sind. Wenn du aber eine Datenbank hast, die halt schnell sein muss, dann kannst du jetzt ein sogenanntes Cache-Device davor schalten, dann kannst du jetzt von Intel die neuen SSD-Flashkarten kaufen, die gerade irgendwie jetzt vorgestellt wurden, die mit 250 Megabyte die Sekunde lesen können. Die kannst du in dein System reinklatschen, die addierst du einfach zu dem Z-Bool dazu. Sagen wir, sie sind 128 GB groß. Dann werden nach so einer Weile, ein paar Stunden irgendwie, vollgeschrieben von dem ZFS. Also der merkt sich, was wird am meisten befragt. Das packt er in diese Cache, also in diese SSDs. Und dann kann er von da schnell lesen und kann die Latenz dadurch niedrig halten. Also sag mal, du hast einen 1 TB Z-Bool. Machst davor einen 128 GB Cache. Und dann kommen diese 128 GB immer total schnell. Und der Rest muss halt weiterhin von dem...
Klar, aber er kann dann die Eilzeit nutzen, um das irgendwie zu füllen.
Und selbst wenn die Karte kaputt geht, dann geht er zum Back-Ed hinten und holt sich die Originaldaten. Falls du die zum Beispiel rausnehmen willst, ist alles gar kein Problem. Oder er kann auch beides gleichzeitig nutzen. Und ich hab das in so einem Minisetup schon auf unserem Musikserver. Und das ist voll toll. Also es ist jetzt nicht, dass es schneller wäre, weil ich hab da nicht so tolle Hardware, aber es funktioniert vom Prinzip auf jeden Fall total super.
Auf jeden Fall ist der aktuelle Stand mit dem ZFS deutlich hinter der aktuellen Entwicklung. Also auf Mac OS X ist die aktuelle ZFS-Version ziemlich weit hinten.
Ist ziemlich weit hinterher. Also 20 Open Solaris größere Versionen. Und die ZFS-Versionen sind die bei 8. Aktuell ist aber gerade eigentlich schon fast 12.
Also mit anderen Worten, selbst wenn Schnee Leo das aktuelle ZFS verpasst bekommt, ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass man auch für Leopard nochmal ein Update bekommt, wo ein neueres ZFS dabei ist.
Sonst könnten alles, was mit Schneeleopard erstellt wird, mit einem alten Leopard nicht lesen. Aber diese neue hat auch gesagt, dass sie auch zurzeit immer noch mit dieser Version 119, die sie da auf dem ZFS-Mac Forged anbieten, dass es trotzdem die Version 6 benutzt vom ZFS, weil es halt die ist, die der Leopard auch lesen kann. Und sie benutzt nicht die 8, die es könnte. Also die halten sich absichtlich runter. Das ist auch nicht so schlimm, weil diese Features, die braucht man nicht unbedingt alle, man muss nicht upgraden, weil es ist schon gefährlich, weil wenn du einen abgegradet hast, kommst du nicht mehr runter.
Also diese Version bezieht sich ja sozusagen auf die Pool-Version, also der On-Disc. Das heißt, wenn man Pool erstellt, kann man auch explizit sagen, dieser Pool bitte in Version, und damit kann ich unter Umständen bestimmte Features nicht nutzen, aber ich kann sozusagen sicherstellen, dass ich zu alten Systemen kompatibel verstehe.
Deswegen beim Upgraden immer vorsichtig sein, weil es hört sich erstmal ganz voll an, cool, neueste Version, ZFS und so. Aber dann kannst du halt eventuell nicht mehr mit anderen sprechen, deswegen muss man da aufpassen. Und bei FreeBestie ist es jetzt Gott sei Dank die 11, die man dann nutzen kann, und bei MacOS ist es halt bisher erst 8. Muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Gut, Thema, das nächste, während ihr hier rumgeklickt über ZFS erzählt habt, hab ich ein bisschen in diesem App Fresh runtergeladen, diese Free Updates Only Option gibt, die du, deren Mangel du dich gerade noch beschwert hast. Also die gibt's.
Ah, okay, man weiß nicht alles.
Man weiß nicht alles.
Das ist gut.
Aber die andere Problematik mit...
Aber auch so die Major hätte ich auch ganz gerne noch. Gibt's da auch ein Hickchen für?
Das seh ich nicht. Und auch die Problematik, dass zum Beispiel, dass er mir sagt, mein iStats-Menu Version 1.3 wäre veraltet, weil es schon eine Version 1.21 gäbe. Das ist genau das Problem, dass da offensichtlich jemand einfach die Version falsch benannt hat. Dass das natürlich eigentlich die Version 1.2.1 ist und dass 1.3 schon die neueste ist, die ich gerade habe.
Genau, das ist nämlich manchmal auch irgendwie total unklar, wer da eigentlich dran schuld ist. Also ob die da jetzt irgendwas falsch machen oder ob das einfach mit dem Developer zu tun hat, keine Ahnung. Ja, so, kurze und knackige Frage. Das hatte ich ja erfordert hier. Was zum Henker ist mit Fake Steve Jobs passiert? Ja, was ist passiert?
Na ja, seine Identität wurde aufgedeckt, so wie von Deep Throat und dann hat er halt keinen Bock mehr gehabt.
Nee, nee, der hat ja noch eine ganze Weile auch weiter...
Er war lange, lange bekannt.
Nee, das war schon lange bekannt, dass es den Lions ist. Aber er hat jetzt einen neuen Job bekommen. Ich hab jetzt vergessen, zu welcher Zeitung er gegangen ist. Na ja, er meinte jetzt auch irgendwie, es wäre jetzt irgendwie auch gut. Da hat er sicherlich Recht. Und jetzt blockt er nicht mehr als Fake Steve Jobs, sondern jetzt blockt er als The Real... Ja, und schreibt aber eigentlich auch immer noch genauso insight-full und lustig. Eigentlich war es aber auch besser. Bitte?
Ich find's sogar ein bisschen besser.
Das Fake Steve Jobs Blog war auch am Schluss echt ein bisschen konfus, wo er dann auch permanent andere Charaktere da aufgezogen hat und die dann da geschrieben haben. Also mir gefiel das eigentlich auch immer nur, wenn er wirklich aus der Position berichtet hat. Na ja, also kann man auf jeden Fall auch lesen, aber ich find das auch ganz cool, dass die Zeit jetzt vorbei ist, weil das war wirklich sehr lustig, fand ich so das Jahr über, als das lief. Irgendwann hat man es dann auch gut, ich mein ich geb ja zu, ich bin auch selber total reingefallen auf seinen Weihnachtsjoke. Ich hab's echt für einen Moment, ich hab's so lange, ich hab's lang genug geglaubt, um so blöd zu sein, drüber zu bloggen.
Das war...
Was war der Weihnachtsjoke, der hat mich auf?
Dass Apple ihn jetzt irgendwie auch unter juristischen Druck setzt, dass er nicht mehr als Fake Steve Jobs auftreten soll.
Da hab ich mich relativ...
Er hat es mal wieder so geschrieben, es war einfach nicht nachgedacht. Es war einfach nur dieses, oh nein, wie können Sie? Ohne wirklich drüber nachzudenken. Vielleicht ist bei ihm immer April. So war es dann auch.
Ich hab mich damals relativ weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt, weil viele geschrieben haben, oh, oh, oh, und weiß ja Teufel was. Der ist doch... Der wird verklagt. Da hab ich relativ schnell gesagt, ich glaub, das sind Fake. Ja, aber The Frank sollte mal wieder kommen. Den vermisse ich wirklich so richtig.
Da musst du mal berichten. Das hab ich, glaub ich, einmal angeklickt. Mich hat das Video nicht so interessiert. Das ist so jemand, der viel in Videos sich aufs Internet gepostet hat, stimmt's?
Sehr, sehr viel und sehr, sehr gut vor allen Dingen.
Das ist umso besser. Ich hab mal was gesehen, das war nicht so mein Geschmack. Vielleicht war das auch nur einmal so.
Ich glaub, das ist falsch.
Keine Ahnung. Bevor wir jetzt hier zu viel Tempo verlieren, im Hintergrund wird fleißig an dem Streaming-Server geschraubt, um die Problematik mit mehreren parallelen Streams aufzuräumen und die Website entsprechend anzupassen. Es gibt jetzt auch ein schönes Archiv für die Mobile-Mac-Sinnung.
Das ist ja genauso schlecht wie bei Mobile Me oder was?
Ich denke, wir haben die Fragen jetzt hier im Wesentlichen durch.
Ja, wir kosten dafür aber nicht ganz so viel.
Was ist mit Mobile Me?
Was hast du gesagt?
Mobile Macs ist ja genauso schlecht wie bei Mobile Me.
Was ist genauso schlecht?
Euer Streaming-Service.
Ach, Schnickschnack, der ist super.
Hallo, hört mich wer?
Der läuft super rock solid. Kannst du jemanden antworten hören? Jungs, lasst euch nicht verarschen. Okay, das waren so die Fragen. Jetzt haben wir vielleicht noch ein paar Lieblingsthemen. Wie lange sind wir eigentlich schon? Oh, wir senden schon. Wir senden schon seit Ewigkeiten, aber aufnehmen tun wir auch schon seit einiger Zeit.
Einiger Zeit ist mal relativ.
2 Stunden 15 Minuten habe ich jetzt hier.
Also ich finde...
Was denn? Was findest du denn?
Ich finde, wir sollten jetzt langsam zum Ende kommen. Echt?
Wieder nicht über Telefon auf dem Mac reden? Ich hab das jetzt schon ein paar Mal versprochen.
Mach schon, aber mach's nicht so lange.
Mach schnell, mach schnell.
Nee, das müssen wir uns schon drüber unterhalten.
Ich würde sagen, wir sollten was ausführlicher zu machen. Das ist doch fast ohne... Oder was meinst du mit Telefon auf dem Mac? Du meinst, das ist ein Modem-Skript.
Jetzt kannst du auch erzählen, das ist eh raus.
Jetzt hast du es gesagt.
Das ist die Katze aus dem Sack. Reingelegt.
Du, ist doch kein großer Deal. Wir wollten einfach nur mal kurz... Es ist halt angefragt worden. Ich hatte mal gesagt, man müsste noch was dazu schreiben. Und dann haben wir gesagt, man müsste was dazu sagen.
Hat auch mal genau gar nichts mit dem iPhone zu tun. Obwohl wir über Telefone reden.
Genau. Und es geht immer echt um den Mac. So. Und als ich auch dazu gestoßen bin, bei Mobile Macs, da war das ja noch so ein bisschen so die Ist-Situation. Internet, Mobil heißt, man zieht sich sein Netz durchs Telefon. Und was halt mich zu dem Zeitpunkt, bis ich mich dann mal ein bisschen intensiver damit beschäftigt habe, immer total verwirrt hat, war so dieses wie, was muss ich eigentlich meinem Computer beibringen, damit ich wirklich so ein Dial-Up richtig hinbekomme. Also, wir reden jetzt über Dial-Up in GSM, respektive UMTS. Weil da ist einfach die Terminologie total verwirrend.
Da braucht man ein Modem-Skript.
Bauch, ja.
Ja, vielleicht sogar auch das. Also ich meine, das erstmal, wie ist denn das Setup? Das Ding ist, du benutzt ja den Datendienst von GSM, bzw. von UMTS.
Oder auch GPRS.
Richtig. So heißt er. Genau. GPRS oder...
Ja, man nutzt ihn.
Auf jeden Fall ist es ja was anderes als Telefonie, weil Telefonie ist connectionorientiert und das ist halt paketorientiert. Und da gibt es zum Beispiel den ersten wirklich verwirrenden Begriff, wo ich eine Weile gebraucht habe, bis ich es geschnellt habe, das ist dieser APN. Weißt du, was der APN ist?
Das ist...
Das muss man auf jeden Fall einstellen.
Sonst geht's nicht. Da muss man immer irgendwas eingeben, zum Beispiel Surf O2 oder Blablabla.blablabla.
Oder Internet.
Internet gerne.
Also, APN steht für Access Point Name. Und das ist einfach der Computer im Telefonnetz, der dir das Internet gibt.
Und mein Computer im Telefonnetz heißt Internet?
Das kann sein. Und bei mir, bei O2, heißt er Surf O2. Internet ist E+, ne?
O2.
Aber das ist doch der, der immer, das ist doch, genau, jetzt geht's nämlich los. Es gibt nämlich mehr als einen. Das gab ursprünglich die...
Weil die unterschiedlich abrechnen, ne?
Genau, die nämlich unterschiedlich abrechnen. Das ist so wie so ein Router, verstehst du? Du schickst, oder so ein Gateway. Du schickst deine Datenpakete vom Telefon zu diesem APN und erst dort wird da Internet draus. Also das ist quasi dein Gateway ins Internet und es gibt verschiedene Gateways. Und je nachdem, welchen du benutzt, hast du auch unter Umständen andere Tarife. Da kann man schnell in die Tariffalle laufen.
Ja, beim iPhone kann man auch einen APN einschalten. Oder muss man zumindest, wenn man sich einen Unlock hat?
Das war nämlich das Fehler, dass die bei der Telekom dann einen Telekom-Vertrag hatten mit T-Mobile und dann einen Jailbreak gemacht haben. Und dann haben wir alles klar, Jailbreak. Und dann rumgesurft sind, wie die Blöden. Dann war der Default-APN eingestellt von T-Mobile, der natürlich nicht der ist für die iPhone-Kunden. Und darum haben sie plötzlich dann fette Rechnungen gekriegt. Und da hat sich T-Mobile zwar wohl mit ein bisschen Diskussion runterhandeln lassen, aber warum das da so viele APNs sind und warum da die ganzen Tarife? Und weißt du was? Die Telcos machen es da wirklich allesamt durch die Bank weg, auch den Leuten schwer.
Auf jeden Fall. Aber das hat was.
Die tragen zum Verwirrung zusätzlich bei.
Genau. Aber dazu muss man erst mal wissen, was ein APN eigentlich ist und tut so. Das heißt, der APN ist der Rechner, der überhaupt aus den Paketen, die aus dem Telefon kommen, auf dem Internet macht.
Dazu muss man aber erst mal von dem Rechner bis zum Telefon kommen.
Genau. So, jetzt die Frage, wie bringe ich mein Telefon dazu, Pakete zu versenden? Also wir rollen es jetzt sozusagen von Netzseite hin zum Rechner auf. Hätte man jetzt auch andersrum machen können. Hat sich jetzt bloß gerade so ergeben. Und wenn du halt dein APN ansprichst, musst du daher auch diese Information irgendwie zum Telefon kriegen. Welchen APN dieses Telefon benutzt. So, und jetzt ist die Frage, was ist dieses Telefon überhaupt für den Rechner? Das gängige Bild, was man halt so hat, ist eben Modem. Modem war früher was. Modem war ein Gerät, das habe ich an meine analoge Telefonleitung angeschlossen. Und dann habe ich mich mit dem Teil über eine serielle Schnittstelle verbunden. Dann hat es mir so einen kleinen Prompt rausgeschmissen. Oder auch nichts gesagt. Und dann konnte ich dann halt so meine Kommandos eingeben und sagen, wähle Telefonnummer. ATDT oder auch ACDP. Ich habe noch... Bei mir hat es noch gerattert. Und dann wird halt die Verbindung hergestellt und dann schickt man eben da so seine Daten rüber. Und du sendest sozusagen einfach nur eine, du hast einfach eine permanente Verbindung. Du sendest halt Daten hin und wieder zurück. Du willst ja auch Pakete haben. Du willst aus dieser seriellen Leitung eine Paketgeschichte machen. Da sind dann halt Protokolle für gemacht worden. Und das populärste kennen wir alle ist PPP.
Was hier bis heute bei jedem DSL-Anschluss im Einsatz ist.
Was heute bei jedem DSL-Anschluss im Einsatz ist, obwohl das eigentlich gar nicht nötig wäre, weil du ja so ein DSL eigentlich auch wie ein Ethernet benutzen könntest. Tatsächlich ist es ja, tatsächlich benutzt du es sogar auch mit Ethernet. Genau. Und du musst aber dann auch PPP über Ethernet machen.
Heißt dann PPP-OE. Genau.
Und zwar musst du das nicht machen, weil du da nicht irgendwie auch Internet kriegen könntest, weil theoretisch könnte das ja ein Ethernet sein, wo ein DHCP-Server läuft und so weiter, wie du das mit deinem normalen Ethernet auch machst.
Wesentlich nachs Abrechnungsgründen, oder? Ich denke schon.
Das ist alles nur, um diese Tarifmodelle durchzusetzen und diese alte Vorstellung wie viele Stunden bist du mit dem Internet verbunden. Ich meine, in einem Paket basierten Netzwerk ist einfach eine Verbindung totaler Quatsch. Genauso wie ich Mobilfunk-Tarife, die halt dir Stunden Internet bereitstellen, vollkommen Quatsch halte.
Wobei es ist nachvollziehbar auch für die Kunden, so halbwegs.
Nein, es ist nicht nachvollziehbar, weil du weißt ja nicht, wann dein Gerät wirklich verbunden ist.
Mittlerweile nicht mehr, aber bei diesen Modellen... Ich brauche jetzt... Also ich probiere jetzt nicht an, hier für die Telcos irgendwie zu sprechen. Da streiten wir nicht drüber.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es wirklich zwingend... Es gibt nicht wirklich gute Gründe dafür, das aufrechtzuerhalten. Sondern das ist alles was damit zu tun, dass sie halt blöde Tarife machen wollen. Eigentlich ist es Quatsch. Eigentlich will man DSL, wo Internet rauskommt und dann ist da einfach Netz dran. So, das würde vollkommen ausreichen. Ja, nicht nur eine Flatrate, aber vor allem auch nicht nochmal eine Wandlung des Protokolls. Weil dieses PPP-Protokoll macht ja aus einer... aus zwei Punkten sozusagen, also aus einer Verbindung zu einem anderen Punkt. PPP, sozusagen etwas, wo man eine Konfiguration rüber schicken kann und wo man eben dann auch Pakete rüber schicken kann. Das ist das Schöne an PPP. Du hast die ganze Konfiguration mit drin. Du kriegst dann irgendwie deinen DNS-Server geliefert und so weiter. An der Stelle macht PPP übrigens auch Sinn, weil du ja auch die Möglichkeit hast, sowas wie einen DNS-Server und so weiter mitzuliefern, den du nicht selber anbauen musst.
Klar, klar.
Das ist ja eine der wichtigsten Sachen.
Wie soll sonst DHCP ohne DNS funktionieren?
Das wird langsam etwas spät.
Zurück zu den Telefonen.
Zurück zu den Telefonen. So, und jetzt kommt der Clou, wo ich nämlich immer selber ein bisschen gegen die Wand gelaufen bin. Die klassische Einbindung eines Telefons hier auf Mac und auch auf Windows ist, dass du halt PPP machst. Und das erste ist, dass ich mir dachte, mein Gott, jetzt machen sie in einem Mobilfunknetz auch PPP. Man würde ja jetzt denken, dass man mit diesem APN PPP macht. Genau.
Man macht nur zwischen Rechner und Telefon PPP.
Genau. Und das ist irgendwie das, wo es sich bei mir irgendwie umgedreht hat, als ich das dann verstanden habe, dass man eben tatsächlich PPP macht, nur um die Verbindung vom Rechner bis zum Telefon zu machen. Und da kommt halt auch dieser APN mit ins Spiel. Und jetzt gibt es sehr unterschiedliche Setups. Und an der Stelle wird es wirklich knifflig, auch mit diesen Modem-Skripten. Was ist die Telefonnummer?
Router 99 Sternchen was für GPS.
Genau, da gibt es verschiedene Sachen. Da gibt es jetzt irgendwie die, die Telefonnummer erfordern mit Stern 99 Router, weil das nämlich eigentlich der WBFel der Telefone ist, um sozusagen Datenkommunikation einzuleiten. Genau. Und dann gibt es halt die, die einfach den APN in der Telefonnummer haben wollen. Also die Modem-Skripte wollen das haben.
Und dann gibt es auch richtige Nummern. Man kann ja auch eine richtige Datenverbindung zu einem anderen Endgerät machen.
Was meinst du jetzt damit?
Man kann ja noch richtig eine Nummer wählen. Eine Gegenstelle.
Das geht noch?
Für eine Datenverbindung.
Was ist das mit dem Telefon? Wählen.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Edge und GPS noch geht. Also ich glaube, das geht nicht.
Natürlich, aber für eine normale 9-6er-Datenverbindung von vor ein paar Jahren, kannst du doch auch eine andere machen.
Achso, ja klar. Das gibt es natürlich auch noch. Du willst halt Paket vermitteln. Du willst halt gleich Pakete losschicken und nicht erst noch eine virtuelle Verbindung aufmachen und darüber dann wirklich nochmal PPP sprechen. Das PPP geht nur bis zum Rechner. Was halt auch immer bei der Konfiguration total verwirrend ist. Je nachdem, welches Modem-Script du einsetzt, das Modem-Script entscheidet, wo du dein APN angibst. Es gibt halt Skripte für bestimmte Netze. Da steht der APN einfach drin. Und da brauchst du auch diese Stern 99-Route nicht angeben. Dann gibt es Skripte, die wollen den APN in der Konfiguration deines Rechners als Telefonnummer haben, damit sie ihn dann als APN übergeben können. Und manche erfordern halt auch noch dieses Stern 99-Route, obwohl das eigentlich bei allen Telefonen identisch ist.
Das liegt vermutlich ein bisschen daran, wenn du mir mal so ein Modem-Script ein bisschen genauer angeguckt hast. Das hast du wahrscheinlich dann im Laufe des Ganzen. Das ist ja eine ziemlich krude Makrodatei. Die sehen immer noch ganz furchtbar aus.
Das gute alte Apple Remote Access.
Und da stehen variable Namen drin. Ich glaube, die fangen auch alle tapfer mit Dollar oder so was an.
Das ist schrecklich. Da will man nicht reingucken.
Da möchte man gar nicht reingucken müssen.
Genau. Und lange Zeit war es jetzt gerade bei diesem GPRS und UMTS fuhr das Problem, dass diese ganzen Modem-Scripten jetzt getalkt haben. Und ich glaube, seit Tiger oder seit Leopard, wo hat sich das so massiv gebessert? Ich glaube, das war, ich weiß es jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, aber seit Leopard sind einfach die Skripte da, die man so braucht, um die meisten UMTS-Telefone einfach anzusprechen.
Also, diese Verbindung ist ja sowieso relativ archaisch. Also, das ist ja eine Bluetooth-Verbindung, die wird ja auch hergestellt, in dem eine virtuelle serielle Schnittstelle eingerichtet wird.
Ja, weil die ja auch immer noch halt...
Da passt das auch ganz gut mit dem PPP zusammen.
Da passt das Konzept noch relativ gut. Genau, man baut eine Verbindung auf über eine serielle Schnittstelle, die aber nicht physisch verhandelt wird.
Aber das liegt wohl auch daran, dass die GSM-Chips in den Telefonen, die brauchen die AT-Commandos, weil das eine einheitliche Schnittstelle für die Telefone ist.
Ich glaube, das ist eine reine Emulation-Schrift.
Nee, die schicken die wirklich immer noch so in die Chips rein.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja auch ein bisschen modernere Protokolle dafür. Was ich ja ganz hübsch finde, ist bei Sony Ericsson Telefonunterstützen, das auf jeden Fall. Da hab ich es ein paar Mal genutzt. Das ist dieses PAN-Protokoll.
Genau, das ist nämlich jetzt die Next Generation.
Das ist das Personal Area Network.
Das ist quasi Ethernet über Bluetooth.
Das ist Ethernet oder IP?
Ja, so Ethernet. Also da benutzt du das Bluetooth, wie du ein Ethernet benutzt. Du hast da so Mac-Adressen und du hast Devices und du kannst da über das Bluetooth direkt die Pakete schicken und musst eben nicht diese Illusion einer seriellen Schnittstelle implementieren, über die du dann mit einem Modem redest, sondern du erkennst einfach das Telefon als Networking Device über Bluetooth. Das sagt, hallo, ich bin ein Pan-Device. Ich habe eine Mac-Adresse und ich schicke dem direkt von meinem Rechner ein Paket rüber an seine Mac-Adresse über Bluetooth, so wie ich jetzt hier, wenn wir hier sitzen, über WLAN oder über Ethernet, das auch tun würde.
Genau, man kann DHCP genauso nutzen. Man kriegt die DNS-Server automatisch übermittelt. Es können mehrere Geräte gleichzeitig drauf zugreifen. Man kann gleichzeitig auf dem Handy auch noch surfen, während man am Rechner surft.
Aber man muss irgendwo noch den APN konfigurieren, oder wie macht man das denn?
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr, und ich habe es auch nicht mehr konfiguriert. Ich habe das Telefon noch nicht gehabt. Nee, nee, nee, du musst es im Gerät konfigurieren. Er nimmt einfach die APN-Konfiguration aus dem Gerät. Was auch sinnvoll ist eigentlich. Das ist extrem sinnvoll. Bei der Einrichtung ist das. Sony Ericsson unterstützt das auf jeden Fall. Nokia unterstützt das, glaube ich, nach wie vor nicht. Jedenfalls das Netzteam Nokia N95, was ich hatte, hat es nicht gehabt. Und wie es bei den anderen Herstellern aussieht, weiß ich nicht. Und das ist wirklich, man verbindet das. Man sagt, in den Systemeinstellungen mit Bluetooth verbinden. Und dann fragt einem irgendwann mal das Mac OS alles klar. Ich frage jetzt mal die Daten an. Und dann richtet es iSync ein. Und dann richtet es das Adressbuchabgleich ein. Und dieses ganze Zeug und die Tastatur. Und dann fragt noch, willst du auch noch vielleicht versehentlich mal darüber das Internet nutzen? Und dann sagst du, klar, warum eigentlich nicht? Und schon ist das ganze Thema gegessen und es funktioniert. Und kein Vergleich im Vergleich zu diesem ich suche irgendwo im Netz nach dämlichen Modem, Skripten und alles ganz furchtbar und so. Und das ist wirklich eine angenehme Sache.
Könnte Apple auch mal ins iPhone einbauen?
Es könnte Apple gerne mal ins iPhone einbauen.
Ich hoffe mal.
Überhaupt ist ihr ganzer Bluetooth-Bereich total unterbelichtet. Keine Tastatur, keine Kopfhörer.
Internet mit Telefon will ich noch mal kurz einen Tipp abgeben. Und zwar habe ich ja früher, weil ich habe ja kein Nokia mehr, also es liegt zu Hause rum. Ich habe das berühmt berüchtigte 63CNI, ganz super tolles Telefon. Und da habe ich auch immer per GPS irgendwie mir ein Netz gemacht mit meinem Rechner. Aber eine Sache, die man beachten muss, ist, dass man diese bei PPP die Echo Packets nicht einschalten darf. Also Echo Packets ist die, dass wenn in der Weile nichts auf der Leitung passiert, schickt das PPP von alleine ein Paket und wartet auf die Antwort, damit sehen kann, ob die Verbindung noch steht. Das heißt, wenn du sowieso chattest, brauchst du das nicht machen, weil dann kommen ja Pakete, dann merkst du es von alleine. Aber wenn in der Weile dann nichts los ist, werden die rausgeschickt. Und irgendwie das PPP vom Nokia kann das irgendwie nicht. Und dann kommt keine Antwort zurück, obwohl die Verbindung noch steht. Und dann denkt der Rechner, die Verbindung ist nicht da und macht sie weg. Und deswegen darf man das nicht einschalten. Und dann funktioniert alles super. Weil ich hab immer gechattet, hab dann eine Weile nicht gechattet. Und dann ist die Verbindung abgebrochen. Und ich wusste immer nicht wieso, bis ich irgendwann festgestellt hab, dass die Verbindung nur abrichtet, wenn ich nichts tue. Und dann hab ich ein bisschen rumgepupelt. Und dann ging's.
Und was ist mit TCP-Header-Compression, was ja auch noch so eine Option ist bei PPP?
Das wird vom Nokia eh nicht unterstützt, glaube ich.
Achso, das ist ja auch eh nur auf dem Weg dahinter. Das verstehe ich nicht, warum das zwischen dem Rechner und dem Telefon so ein Problem sein soll, diese Echo-Packs hin und her zu schicken.
Weil es einfach nicht geantwortet hat, das Nokia haben sie nicht implementiert.
Achso, okay, verstehe. Das heißt, es würde austeilen, weil es einfach nicht, ja, macht Sinn. Ja, man kann ja so einiges konfigurieren, aber eigentlich will man sowas alles gar nicht konfigurieren und irgendwie redialen für ein Netzwerkgerät, was direkt daneben liegt, das ist einfach alles so bekloppt und sinnlos. Das muss alles weg.
Was ist jetzt mit Modem Script? Das ist doch ein schönes Motto für die Sendung, oder? Das muss alles weg.
Das muss alles weg.
Wir müssen jetzt auch weg.
Ja, wir müssen auch weg. Und jetzt haben wir doch wieder mal hier, na, 2 Stunden und 30 Minuten.
Und, wie viele haben durchgehalten?
Ich weiß nicht genau. Das ist gerade etwas schwierig zusammenzufassen, weil das Streaming-Server die Chaos Radio und die Mobile Macs-Hörer in eine Statistik wirft. Ich glaube, da ist demnächst mal ein Software-Update fertig, das von vornherein auseinanderklamm büsert.
62 haben wir, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Auf... Also da steht MM hinter. Ich nehme an, das heißt Mobile Macs.
Ach so, hat sich da schon wieder was getan während der Sendung. Ja, ich hatte jetzt keine Gelegenheit da reinzuschauen. Na ja, ich sehe schon. Jetzt wird es nach Sendung unterschieden. Das ist ja schon mal sehr schick. Und Statistiken dann auch, oder was?
Meint ihr, dass auf dem iPhone es noch mal irgendwie Support gibt, dass man mit seinem Rechner irgendwie ein Netz kriegt?
Wir hatten das ja schon mal in Deutschland. Das wäre eigentlich kein Thema. Aber international, glaube ich, haben halt nicht alle Provider diese Wunsch, die Laptops mit drauf zu lassen.
Es gab doch schon mal im App Store im App Store, gab es noch mal eine Zeitlang?
Ja, bescheiden nur irgendwie ein Socks 5 Proxy oder irgendwie sowas, das reicht ja noch mal nicht. Das ist kein Netz.
Ja, aber wir können doch aus der Tatsache, dass es diese Software nicht mehr gibt, ungefähr erahnen, was Apple davon hält, oder? Nämlich im Augenblick noch nicht allzu viel.
Was Apple davon hält und was die Verträge mit den Providern davon halten, das ist, glaube ich, so der Unterschied. Da kann man jetzt wieder nur Mut maßen und das wollen wir ja nicht. Also wir fassen zusammen, wir fänden das eigentlich alles ganz okay.
Hier ist dieses Zeug Pan, das hätte ich gerne.
Pan hättest du gerne für das.
Ihr seid ja immer noch im Quatschen.
Ja, das stimmt. Also lassen wir das jetzt sein. Und sagen Winke Winke, oder? Und das war's. Mobile Macs Nummer 11.
Spaß gemacht.
Schnapsal.
Achso, wir sollen singen. Letztes Mal haben wir gesungen. Aber am Ende des Streams haben wir gesungen, nicht am Ende der Sendung.
Der Stream hast du jetzt schon ausgemacht? Dann kann ich schon mal offiziell Tschüss sagen. Ich nehm auch noch auf. Auch noch? Ich singe eh nicht.
Du meinst, wir singen nur auf dem Stream?
Nee, machen wir so halt.
Gut, das ist der Mehrwert. Also, Tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.